Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mir doch mal warum bist du so spät gekommen heute?
Ich habe meine Magnetschwebebahn verpasst.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 476 vom 20.
November 2023 und mit uns geht es, wir schweben in die Zukunft.
Kurzstreckenmagnetschwebebahn machen wir jetzt.
Vom Hauptbahnhof in München bauen wir die.
Einfach dann dauert es auch nur 10 Minuten bis zum Flughafen.
Die ist quasi schon da.
Die steckt direkt in den Hauptbahnhof ein.
Die steckt, weil das ja klar ist.
Warum verstehen die Leute das immer nicht? Zukunft kann so einfach sein.
Man denkt sich einfach irgendeinen Scheiß aus und dann kündigt man den an.
So geht das. Ist ganz einfach. Wir machen es nicht immer voll.
Wir denken immer alles nach und wägen alles ab und schauen uns die Details an
und die Implikationen und die Auswirkungen und man muss aber auch mal genau
nachdenken. Nee, so funktioniert Politik einfach nicht.
Politik heißt einfach, hallo, wir haben eine Scheißidee, die machen wir jetzt,
weil ich habe einen Freund getroffen auf so einem Meeting irgendwie beim Kaffee
oder beim Wein in irgendeinem übertäuten Restaurant und der hat gesagt, das ist voll geil.
Eine Kurzstreckenmagnetspiegelbahn ist wirklich was, da muss man schon weit
verfahren, um jemanden zu finden, der das kaufen will.
Aber in Berlin ist das eine Kurzstrecke.
In Berlin ist Inkompetenz ein Trademark.
Und keiner hat das so sehr am Revier wie die CDU.
Ich meine erinnern wir uns, was hat die CDU schon alles vergeigt in Berlin? Eigentlich alles.
Schuldenbergaufgabe, komplett bei Immobilien verzorgt, die Stadt muss noch irgendwie
auf Jahrzehnte dieses Desaster abbezahlen, deswegen hat Berlin die ganze Zeit keine Kohle.
Kaum ist die CDU wieder da, kommen erstmal die geilen Ideen,
die man heute so braucht.
Ja die Radwege und Straßenbahnen, das nimmt ja nur Platz weg irgendwie,
dann können wir ja nicht mehr mit unseren dicken Schlitten irgendwie durch die
Straßen fahren, da müssen wir uns was anderes ausdenken.
Und dann so, ja, kommt einer an, sagt er so, ja hier noch eine Magnetschwebebahn,
die schwebt dann über allem drüber, nimmt dann keine Parkplätze weg.
Wenn die die gebaut kriegen ohne, dass die Parkplätze wegnimmt,
das glauben wir selber nicht.
Das ist nämlich, weißt du, geil ist ja die Begründung, die Begründung,
warum bauen sie Magnetschwebebahnen, ist einfacher als eine U-Bahn.
Ist einfacher und ist kein Fahrrad drin, außerdem haben sie sich ja noch nicht
festgelegt, wo sie die bauen wollen und auch noch nicht festgelegt, wann.
Die kommen auch nicht rum die Leute, also dass sie mal in eine Stadt fahren,
wo man mal eine U-Bahn sieht, wo auch kein Fahrrad drin ist,
das gibts überall nur in Berlin.
Und was ich glaube, woran es scheitern wird, ist genau das, was du sagst,
also die, üblicherweise baut man die halt dann auf, also kannst du machen,
ja, aber dann baust du die halt auf Füßen, ne, also dann machst du halt eine elevated,
also wie heißt so eine Brücke, auf die du baust, ne, also auf so eine Hochbahn.
Und ich glaube, ich glaube, da wo unten dann die Füße sind, wo die Hochbahn
drauf steht und dann darauf schwebt, da kann keiner parken.
Ich glaube da kann keiner parken und damit ist das ganze Ding sowieso erledigt.
Ich meine, eine Sache wirklich, also U-Bahn kannst du sagen was du willst,
aber nimmt echt verflucht wenig Parkplätze weg.
Das muss man wirklich nur in der U-Bahn lassen so.
Ist ein parkplatzfreundliches Verkehrsmittel.
Deswegen wollen sie ja auch gerne U-Bahn bauen, aber dann stellen sie mal fest,
das ist so teuer und so schwierig.
Und dann wollen sie ja aber, da wo es aber Sinn macht, ne, eine U-Bahn zu bauen,
wie zum Beispiel da unten in Rudow, wo um seit Jahren die U-Bahn so quasi gefühlt,
200 Meter vom Flughafen verreckt, da müssen sie jahrzehntelang drüber nachdenken,
ob das eine gute Idee ist, die U-Bahn, die sowieso schon 20 Kilometer zurückgelegt,
hat und jetzt einfach noch so die letzten paar Meter zum Flughafen.
Wer fährt denn mit der U-Bahn zum Flughafen? Das sind doch nur die Plebs.
Das braucht doch keiner. So hat es ja auch Berlin geschafft,
den Flughafen Tegel in seiner gesamten, in seinem halben Jahrhundert seiner
Existenz, Wo ist der Bus hin?
Noch nicht mal mit der Straßenbahn anzubinden oder sonst irgendwas. So ein scheiß Bus.
Boisselstraße und dann in so ein Bus.
Der immer voll und zu spät ist.
Aber Tegel war ein Taxi-Flughafen. Also ich bin immer mit dem Taxi nach Tegel
gefahren und es war jedes Mal geil. Es war einfach geil.
Es war geil. Einmal bin ich sogar mit dem Auto dahin gefahren und hab dann unten
in dem Ding geparkt, der unten drunter ist ein Parkhaus und da konntest du,
du konntest nicht nur mit dem Taxi an deinem Gate fahren,
sondern du konntest mit deinem Auto unten in diesen Flughafen rein und dann
stand da A3 und dann hast du da geparkt und dann bist du mit dem Fahrstuhl hochgefahren
und dann bist du auch gebordet.
War super, hat aber glaube ich irgendwie 100 Euro am Tag parken gekostet,
das war so ein bisschen der Nachteil. Aber geil.
Also nur mit dem Bus nach Tegel fahren war mir immer ein bisschen,
aber ich bin sowieso, wer mich kennt weiß, Busse.
Nicht dein Ding?
Nee. Busse sind für mich die Kombination, also von allen Fahrzeugen das schlechteste.
Also in der Stadt? Ja.
Ja auf Langstreckebus.
Ja wieso?
Also es gibt einen Bus den ich fahre, den fahre ich, das ist der Busliner,
aber alle anderen Busse meide ich.
Ich beschwere mich auch wenn ein Flugzeug landet und man muss dann mit dem Bus
zum Flughafen fahren, da schreibe ich jedes Mal eine Beschwerde.
Also auf dem Land macht ein Bus auch schon Sinn, wenn er denn fährt.
Das Problem sind ja hier nicht die Busse. Mit Bussen könnte man durchaus einiges fixen in Berlin.
Vor allem mit Elektrobussen, das scheint ja die BVG langsam auf den Zettel zu
kriegen, dass das irgendwie alles eine gute Idee ist.
Aber jetzt haben wir es halt wieder hier mit so einer Vision zu tun,
dieses Verkehrsressort.
Also wer es überhaupt noch nicht mitbekommen hat und sich die ganze Zeit fragt,
worüber reden die Leute eigentlich die ganze Zeit.
CDU Berlin kam jetzt wieder mit einem Vorschlag raus, ja ne irgendwie alles
andere ist doch Quatsch, wir bauen jetzt eine Magnetschwebebahn.
Und das geile ist, das gab es ja schon mal.
Also sie wollen jetzt eine Teststrecke bauen, für eine Magnetschwebebahn, die M-Bahn.
Die gab's schon. Die ist dann jahrelang im Testbetrieb hin und her gefahren,
und hat dann irgendwie so ein oder zwei Jahre,
ist sie dann irgendwie regulär gefahren, gab aber nur drei oder vier Haltestellen,
hat halt kaum einer benutzt, weil Problematik, Umsteigen und so weiter,
du kriegst das ja einfach mit den ganzen anderen Verkehrssystemen überhaupt
nicht richtig kombiniert und vor allem, wo willst du diese Trassen hernehmen?
Also du willst ja nicht da mit so einem komischen Teil da quer durch die Stadt
durchschlängeln, da wird ja jeder gegen klagen.
Ist ja schon schwierig genug in Berlin eine Straßenbahnlinie irgendwie mal durch
eine Straße gelegt zu bekommen, ich sag nur Ostkreuz.
Und das ist ein feuchter Fiebertraum von Leuten,
die einfach die ganze Zeit nur einer Autofahrerlobby dienen wollen und die die
ganze Zeit sagen, unsere Parkplätze müssen aber bleiben und Fahrspuren auch.
Und es ist einfach, es ist einfach nur, es ist einfach, also das,
ein Magnetschwebband ist ein richtig geiles Verkehrsmittel für die Langstrecke,
weil du das, wenn du das Ding einmal in Bewegung hast und dann schön mit deinem
Magnet da lang schwebst und so, ne, und das irgendwie, dann kann das richtig
schön seine Vorteile ausspielen.
Aber wenn das alle paar Meter anhält und wieder losfährt und damit mehr steht
als es fährt, dann verliert es halt seinen Effizienzvorteil.
Und ich bin mir sicher, dass wir jetzt, das muss ich jetzt nur kurz sagen,
damit wir in der nächsten Sendung als Feedback relativ ausführliche Betrachtung
der Energieeffizienz von Magnetschwebebahnen im Vergleich der Kurzstrecke zur
Langstrecke haben und das einfach als Abhandlung hier nächste Woche verlesen können. Aber es ist...
Vor allem, es ist ja schon ein Mem, dass ganze Städte ruiniert werden damit,
dass man ihnen eine Magnetschwebebahn aufschwatzt.
Und am Ende haben sie diese Magnetschwebebahn-Leichen in der Landschaft stehen, ja.
Es ist vollkommen sinnlos und es ist vor allem, es ist alles schon mal getestet
worden, es macht keinen Sinn und mal abgesehen von diesen ganzen physikalischen
Gründen, die schon dagegen sprechen,
es ist halt auch einfach aus verkehrsorganisatorischer Sicht vollkommener Unsinn,
weil du kannst übrigens auch schnell mit Zügen fahren, das ist überhaupt gar
kein Problem, kannst auch mit einer U-Bahn schnell fahren.
Die kann einen super Takt machen und was die Physik betrifft,
wenn die bremst, dann erzeugt die sogar noch Strom und braucht nicht Strom.
Aber es ist einfach existierende Technologie, da weiß man, was das kostet.
Das ist relativ günstig.
Dann dieses Argument, man könnte damit ja auch Cargo machen.
Das kann man auch übrigens mit einer U-Bahn, wenn man das mal ordentlich plant.
Warum gibt es keine Cargo-U-Bahn?
Ich meine früher hatten wir hier so ein Luftpostsystem in Berlin,
da wurden dann die Nachrichten irgendwie mit Luft durchs Rohr gedrückt.
Die ganzen Pakete, die in Berlin ausgeliefert werden, die könnten auch über
die Schiene rollen, wenn man das dann halt alles entsprechend organisiert bekommt.
Aber so kriegt man halt nichts organisiert, wenn man die ganze Zeit die Investitionen
in die falsche Richtung bringt. Aber wir sind ja kein Verkehrspodcast.
Nee, aber ich möchte, wir sind ein Kultur-Podcast und ich möchte darauf hinweisen, ja.
Politik und Kultur habe ich mir jetzt überlegt. Wir könnten eigentlich über
Politik, Kultur und Gesellschaft sprechen.
Logbuch, Netz, Kultur.
Ich möchte nur kurz anmerken, dass es 30 Jahre her ist, dass das Thema Magnetfilme
waren, bei denen Simpsons abschließend erörtert wurde. Es ist 30 Jahre her, 14.
Januar 1993, March vs. The Monorail, geschrieben von Conan O'Brien,
ja da gibt's einen kompletten Wikipedia-Eintrag drüber,
inklusive dem,
Monorail-Song,
von Conan O'Brien und AI-Gene,
weiß,
ich,
nicht,
wer,
das ist, L-Gene? Ne, ist wahrscheinlich L, ja,
AI-L.
Ja, ein Wikipedia-Entrag mit 36 Referenzen.
Also das Thema ist tatsächlich wirklich lange, schon lange abschließend erwörtert.
Ähnlich wie alle anderen Themen, die wir hier behandeln.
Ja, es macht einfach keinen Sinn und es ist einfach traurig zu sehen,
dass die Stadt Berlin jetzt noch mal weitere vier Jahre mindestens verschenkt.
Die nächste Wahl ist ja gar nicht so weit weg.
Also auf jeden Fall ein paar Jahre verschenkt, mal irgendwie ordentlich durchzustarten in der Zukunft.
Wir haben uns jetzt mal aufgeregt ein bisschen, aber wir danken auch für die
Vorlagen, immer wieder, für Witze.
Kommen wir zu den anderen Fehlern und Witzen, die wir hier so gemacht haben.
Feedback gab es wieder richtig gut.
Los geht es mit Österreich. Gregor merkt an zu Österreich.
Karneval gibt es in Österreich auch, heißt allerdings Fasching.
Okay, warum weiß Thomas sowas nicht? Was kann Thomas eigentlich?
Der ist immer auf EU-Ebene und so, der hat das Land hinter sich gelassen.
Achso, auf EU-Ebene gibt es auch kein Karneval oder was?
Ich glaube das hat der vielleicht sogar erwähnt, dass es Fasching heißt.
Was machen die denn da die ganze Zeit da in der EU? Das ist doch auch die ganze
Zeit so ein, naja egal, verkleiden und so.
Zweiter Hinweis, Graz ist nicht in der Nähe von Italien, sondern von Slowenien.
Und da muss ich sagen, ich habe nachgeguckt, stimmt.
Graz ist sehr viel mehr im Osten, als ich das in Erinnerung hatte.
Und tatsächlich, wenn man da so durchstartet, dann landet man in Slowenien.
Und ich war schon mal in Graz, aber ich war noch nie in Slowenien.
Ich glaube das nächste Mal nach Graz fahre ich auch gleich nach Slowenien,
das passiert mir nicht nochmal.
So zum Fasching merkt GR9 an, also Fasching jetzt sozusagen der Karneval in Österreich.
Damit wurde natürlich ein komplett neues Thema eröffnet.
Ja, die Kommentare die geben sich hier wirklich auch die Klinke in die Hand. Zum Opernball.
Laut Wikipedia hat die Ballsaison sehr wohl etwas mit Karneval,
Fastnacht bzw. Fasching zu tun.
Dort heißt es, der Wiener Opernball ist jedes Jahr neben dem Philharmonikaball
der gesellschaftliche Höhepunkt der Ballsaison im Wiener Fasching.
Er findet immer in der Wiener Staatsoper statt, üblicherweise am letzten Donnerstag
vor dem Aschermittwoch.
Und der letzte Donnerstag vor Aschermittwoch ist Weiberfastnacht slash Alt-Weiber,
und der Auftakt des rheinischen Straßenkarnevals.
Viele Grüße aus dem Rheinland. Das war mir schon irgendwie klar,
dass jetzt die ganzen Experten aus dem Westen kommen, aber das ist ja auch schön,
wenn der Westen mal was weiß.
Nehmen wir das gedankend an. Also Thomas, Ballsaison ist quasi auch Fasching.
Da muss man sich dann auch nicht mehr so richtig wundern.
So, aber es geht weiter, es wird noch besser. Zum Thema Helau und Alarv und
ich garantiere dir Linus, das wusstest du auch nicht.
Christian Jakob schreibt, um mal eure Frage hinsichtlich Bedeutung der Ausrufe
Helau und Alarv zu beantworten.
Diese beiden Ausrufe stammen aus dem 12. bzw. 13.
Jahrhundert und stammen aus der Rheinschifffahrt.
Korrekt mit 3F geschrieben. Der Rhein war zur damaligen Zeit Hauptverkehrsader
für den Handel und dem Transport von Gütern und Waren.
Da Köln als auch Düsseldorf Zollstädte waren, gab es zur damaligen Zeit eine Regelung.
Sämtliche Schiffe, die rheinabwärts kamen, hatten Waren aus dem Hinterland,
also rheinaufwärts, geladen, um diese bis in die Niederlande zu transportieren
und dort zu verkaufen bzw.
Die großen Schiffe in Amsterdam und Rotterdam zu beliefern.
Aufgrund der Zollbestimmungen wurde jedes Schiff, was den Rhein hinabfuhr,
mit einer Zwangsabgabe von einem Zehntel der geladenen Waren bzw.
Güter belegt, die vor Ort auf den Kölner Märkten angeboten werden mussten.
Erst danach durften die Schiffe wieder ablegen und ihre Fahrt den Rhein hinab fortsetzen.
Wenn ein beladenes Schiff den Rhein hinunter fuhr, kam es als erstes an Köln vorbei.
Die Kapitäne riefen bei der Vorbeifahrt am Kölner Rheinhafen Alav aus,
was so viel bedeutet wie alles abladen zu müssen.
Je nach Gütern oder Waren wurde dann im Hafen entschieden, ob das Schiff anlanden
musste oder weiterfahren konnte.
Nach dieser aufwändigen und zeitraubenden Aktion setzten die Schiffe ihre Fahrt
den Rhein hinab weiter fort und kamen dann an Düsseldorf vorbei.
Auch hier hatte man als Auflage die Zwangsabgabe von einem Zehnt der Ladung vorgeschrieben.
Jedoch gab es einige Kapitäne, die sich diesen Zeit- und kostenaufwändigen Aufwand
nicht leisten konnten und.
Gaben dem Schiff aus dem Ausruf »Mir sinn helau«, was so viel bedeutet wie,
dass das Schiff leer ist oder nur noch wenige Waren an Bord hat.
Übrigens ist der Kölner Karneval ebenfalls eine Tradition aus dieser Zeit und
ist der Ursprung dieser heutigen Festivitäten, die überall auf der Welt kopiert wurden.
Die damals noch mächtige Kirche entschied zusammen mit den Obern der Stadt Köln,
dass es einmal im Jahr eine Art Dampfablassen geben muss, damit die Menschen
sich nicht unterdrückt fühlen.
So kam es, dass am Altweiberdonnerstag eines jenen Jahres das Rathaus gestürmt
werden konnte, um mit den oberen Schabernack zu treiben.
Diese ganze Prozedur dauerte sechs Tage bis zum Aschermittwoch.
In dieser Zeit durfte man als normaler Kölner verbotene Waren wie Kakao,
Bier, Wein, Fleisch, Zucker etc.
In der Fastenzeit konsumieren.
Wenn das generiert ist, ist es super. Ja, also damit können wir uns ja auch
die ganze Zeit beschäftigen, dass wir uns einfach die ganze Zeit mit Chachipiti,
welchen Kunstgeschichten einfallen lassen, aber wir werden sehen.
Ich glaube, Tim, du hast da gerade absoluten Bullshit vorgetragen.
Wieso?
Also ich find das nicht.
Also, ich finde überhaupt nichts zu Schifffahrt und Alarv.
Ursprüngliches Wort ist Al-Av, alles ab, alles weg, auch in Trinksprüchen.
Interessant.
Okay, also, ja doch, Handelsschiff, das ab 1259,
aber seit Erneuerung des Karnevals, also Alaw gibt es seit 1635.
Eine dem Kölner Alaf ähnliche Formulierung ist zum ersten Mal in der Bitschrift
des zu Köln geborenen Geheimenrats Metternich zugracht an seinen Kurfürsten
für das Jahr 1635 schriftlich will.
Ursprüngliches Wort ist Al-Af, alles ab, alles weg, auch in Trinksprüchen legen
Inschriften auf Bärtmänner nahe, einige solcher artbeschriftete Krüge aus der
Zeit um 1550 werden im kölnischen Stadtmuseum aufbewahrt.
Und den 18er, scheiße jetzt haben sie sowas eingelassen.
Also ich hab jetzt mal Chachipiti gefragt.
Und Chachipiti gibt dir den Kommentar?
Naja erstmal hat er dazu nix gesagt, sondern dann hab ich gefragt hat das irgendwas
mit der Rheinschefahrt und dem Zollsystem zusammen und dann kommt so ja es gibt
diese These sozusagen ja,
eine Theorie besagt, dass der Ausdruck aus dieser Zeit stammt und genau hier
heißt es der Ruf Allah könnte ursprünglich ein Signal der Schiffer gewesen sein,
dass darauf hinwies, dass sie keine verbotenen Waren an Bord hatten und bereit
waren den Zoll zu entrichten.
Das würde jetzt dieser Darstellung entsprechen.
Genau.
Jetzt frage ich nochmal nach Helau. Hängt das auch mit Helau zusammen?
Das finde ich ja wirklich so interessant. Ich meine, man kann sich natürlich
auf nichts mehr so richtig verlassen. Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Aber um solche Sachen.
Du kannst halt damit auch wirklich durch gezieltes Fragen einfach bestimmte
Wahrheiten rauskratzen, für die es jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres eine Quelle gibt.
Und das ist schon interessant, also ich bin mal gespannt wie das so,
ich muss mal so ein bisschen meine Erinnerung der Vor-Internet-Zeit mal ein,
bisschen abgrasen. Mal gucken was dabei rauskommt.
So wie das deutsche Internet entstanden ist und so. Man muss das ja eben mit
eigener Erfahrung kombinieren.
Das deutsche Internet, das wird ja noch gebaut.
Ja, also dieses mir sind lau, das finde ich jetzt sozusagen nicht,
aber wir werden jetzt einfach gucken, was das Rheinland, das Rheinland muss jetzt liefern.
Das steht jetzt an. Das Rheinland muss jetzt liefern.
Ich will jetzt hier eine breite Diskussion, in der das abschließend geklärt
wird mit Quellen und allem und volles Programm.
Also ich glaube da wird irgendjemand lacht sich gerade Schrott, dass er irgendwelchen,
also bitte Che Che Petit erzähl mir eine völlig absurde Geschichte über Alaf
und Helau und dann hat er sich jetzt Kommentar eingegossen und sitzt jetzt gerade
zu Hause und lacht sich Schrott. Ich glaube das ist passiert.
Ich glaube es nicht, aber wir werden ja sehen was bei rauskommt.
Aber wir sind ja nur euer Entertainment Kanal, wir verdichten das jetzt hier
einfach nur zur allgemeinen Belustigung.
Was haben wir mit Fakten am Hut?
Wollen wir mit anderen Kommentaren weitermachen, die sich jetzt erstmal nicht
mit Fasching beschäftigen.
Ich hätte da was zum OLG Köln und Cloudflare im Angebot, bevor es wieder billig wird.
Da musst du jetzt aber mal gut zuhören, weil ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher,
ob ich das beim ersten Mal schon alles verstanden habe, als sie es gelesen haben.
Ich hab schon gelesen und verstanden, ja.
Aha, ok. Soll ich es trotzdem vorlesen?
Ja bitte, die anderen müssen das ja hören, die nicht hier sind gerade.
Daniel trägt bei, zum OLG, also Oberlandesgericht oder Oberlandgericht,
wie war das? Landesgericht, ne?
Das ist doch echt so, wir sind so ianal, das ist schon fast anal.
Zum OLG Köln und Cloudflare habe ich es so verstanden, schreibt Daniel.
Paragraph 8 TMG, da müssen wir jetzt kurz erklären, was die jeweiligen Paragraphen tun.
Müssen wir das?
Willst du Chatschip in die Frage oder sowas? Lieber googeln.
Durchleitung von Informationen.
Ich geb das jetzt erstmal so wieder wie es hier steht.
Paragraph 8 TMGG ist für wer die Übermittlung nicht veranlasst,
die Adressaten nicht ausgewählt hat, der einfach nur durchleitet.
Okay, also das sei nicht anwendbar im Falle von Cloudflare, die ja verdonnert wurden.
Also Cloudflare ist verklagt worden vom Oberlandesgericht Köln, so nach dem Motto,
ihr müsst jetzt hier sperren, weil wir nehmen euch nicht ab,
dass ihr irgendwie ein Content Distribution Network seid, sondern ihr seid auch
selber quasi wie ein Anbieter der Informationen, auch wenn das gar nicht eure
Informationen sind, zu behandeln.
So habe ich es verstanden. So und Daniel erläutert sozusagen die Argumentation.
Also Paragraph 8 TMG sei nicht anwendbar, weil dein CDN nicht nur Daten durchleitet,
also Köln an Cloudflare, sondern auch selber Kopien erstellen,
also Caches und damit die Daten auch speichert.
Und Paragraph 9 TMG, wo genau für solch ein CDN ein Haftungsprivileg verankert
ist, wurde vom OLG nicht anerkannt, weil, salopp gesagt, das OLG Cloudflare
schlicht nicht geglaubt hat, als CDN zu agieren.
Es wurde wohl nicht vorgetragen, Zitat, inwieweit es sich bei der Speicherung
um einen automatisierten Vorgang handelt,
welche vertraglichen Vereinbarungen es hierzu gibt und in welchem Rahmen die
Kunden, hier die Verantwortlichen der Seite ddlmusic.to.
Die Zwischenkopien bei ihrer Anlegung dediziert.
Als zeitlich begrenzt widmen. Weiter fehlt es an Vortrag und Glaubhaftmachung,
wie die konkrete Konfiguration der eigenen Server der Antragsgegnerin diesbezüglich
aussieht und ob sich das ob und wie der Speicherung ganz im Sinne einer Effizienzsteigerung
nach Speicherkapazität,
der Größe und Aktivität der Nutzergemeinde sowie der Abrufhäufigkeit richten.
Ey Leute, schreibt mal Sätze, die man auch versteht.
Das Gericht war nicht davon überzeugt, dass Cloudflare sein Geschäftsmodell ist.
Das ist auch wirklich das Geschäftsmodell. Sie verkaufen es zwar allen,
aber das Gericht kauft dir das nicht ab, naja jeder baut was.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ich das erklärt habe mit dem Katsching,
also da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Dann trägt er noch nach, auf Paragraph 9 TMG wurde nur hingewiesen,
es fehlt wohl tatsächlich die Darlegung und zack hat das Gericht es nicht geprüft,
weil keine Begrünung für Paragraph 9 TMG vorgetragen wurde.
Jetzt kommt wieder ein Zitat, das ist wieder so lang. Soll ich das auch vorlesen?
Ja klar, jetzt hast du angefangen.
Paragraph 9 TMG sei vom Landgericht nicht geprüft worden,
obwohl die Antragsgegnerin darauf hingewiesen habe, dass ihre Dienste unter
Paragraph 8 und oder 9 fielen in Bezug auf die Performancesteigerung durch Zwischenspeicherung
sei dieser Aspekt geradezu ein Musterbeispiel eines Caching-Dienstes,
im Sinne von Paragraph 9 TMG.
Genau, denn Paragraph 9 ist Zwischenspeicherung zur beschleunigten Übermittlung von Informationen.
Die Erweiterung der Sicherheit und Kapazität dürfe kein höheres Haftungsrisiko
nach sich ziehen, wolle man das Wachstum des Internets nicht erheblich beeinträchtigen.
Dienstanbieter sind für Paragraf 9 automatische, zeitlich begrenzte Zwischenspeicherung,
die allein dem Zweck dient, die Übermittlung fremder Informationen an andere
Nutzer auf deren Anflage effizienter zu gestalten, nicht verantwortlich.
Sofern sie diese Information nicht verändern, die Bedingungen für den Zugang
zu den Informationen beachten, die Regeln für die Aktualisierung beachten,
die erlaubte Anwendung und so weiter unverzüglich handeln und so weiter.
Also ich denke schon, dass die Formulierung Cloudflare, CDN ist ein Paradebeispiel
für die Zwischenspeicherung zur beschleunigten Übermittlung von Informationen.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich schon so sagen, ne.
Ja gut, man muss sich natürlich jetzt fragen, ob dieses TMG hier in irgendeiner
Form eigentlich noch zeitgemäß ist.
Oder?
Aber, also 8 und 9 sagen, wenn du das machst, bist du nicht verantwortlich.
Und das Urteil war ja, Cloudflare ist verantwortlich.
Genau, das heißt, weil die Definition da drin sozusagen nicht auf das greift,
was Cloudflare macht in der Perspektive des Gerichtes.
Ich glaube, das Gericht hat nicht verstanden, was Cloudflare macht.
Ja, das kann auch sein. Oder es wurde ja nicht ausreichend mitgeteilt. Na ja, schauen wir mal.
Also ich hab den Kommentar jetzt so verstanden, auf TMG 9 wurde nur hingewiesen,
es fehlt aber die Darlegung, also die haben gesagt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
haben die gesagt, es gibt Paragraph 9, kennt ihr, ne?
Und hat das Gericht gesagt, ja kennen wir, aber ihr habt euch ja nicht darauf
berufen, insofern prüfen wir den nicht.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Anwälte haben es verkackt?
Ich glaube eher die Richterin. Eigentlich beide, also die Richterin hat's… Paragraph
9 wurde von dem Landgericht nicht geprüft, obwohl die Antragsgegnerin darauf hingewiesen habe.
Zwischen… haben wir sie nicht geprüft.
Tja, prüfen wir nicht, machen wir nicht.
Und weil das ORG gesagt hat, naja, ich glaub nicht, dass ihr ein CDN seid.
Okay, ey, kann man vielleicht auch einfach mal, also ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass es jetzt irgendwelche juristischen Tricks gibt, um zu erklären,
warum dieses falsche Urteil gefallen ist, aber vielleicht können wir uns auch
einfach darauf einigen,
dass da jemand einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Den Eindruck macht es auf jeden Fall.
Aber OLG ist natürlich schon ein bisschen weiter, bis erst beim Amtsgericht,
dann beim Landgericht, dann beim Oberlandesgericht.
Und dann?
Weiß ich nicht.
Was kommt denn dann als nächstes?
Kommt bestimmt noch was. Ok, nächster Kommentar.
Verfassungsgericht.
Das bringen wir bis zum EuGH.
Naja, mal gucken. So, nächster Kommentar bezieht sich auf die Ausweis-App.
Bin mir gar nicht so sicher, haben wir die auch explizit nochmal angesprochen?
Ja, du hast die Ausweis-App angesprochen. Wir haben ja über die IIDAS gesprochen,
dann hast du dich über die Ausweis-App 2 echauffiert und das wurde sofort gehört.
Also da wurde unmittelbar reagiert.
Ja natürlich, klar. Wenn jemand was im Internet falsch sagt,
dann kommt es immer sofort.
Also sowohl Max als auch Retro-Kommentierten im Sinne von die Ausweis-App 2,
heißt inzwischen Ausweis-App.
Sie wurde kürzlich umgetauft. Fun Fact, die Umbenennung erfolgte ausgerechnet mit Version 2.0.
Das war Ihnen dann wahrscheinlich auch zu doof. Ausweisapp 2.0.
Ich meine so sehr viel besser ist es jetzt auch nicht geworden muss ich sagen,
weil ich halte ja auch nach wie vor den Namen Ausweisapp für vollkommen hirntot.
Na gut, aber was ist denn eine Ausweis-App?
Aber man schreibt doch nicht App in... Also...
Ist doch geil. Es ist das Release 2.0.0 und die Änderungen sind Umbenennung
der Ausweis-App zur Ausweis-App.
Es ist einfach, wer denkt sich sowas aus? Was ist das für Menschen? Ausweis-App.
Also man schreibt doch nicht in App, App schreiben.
Also es ist so ungefähr wie ein Podcast, Podcast nennen, ne?
Ein bisschen. Also jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, es gibt ja auch WhatsApp,
aber das ist ja zumindest noch ein Witz in gewisser Hinsicht,
zwar kein guter, aber naja.
Also was ich eigentlich daran kritisiere ist, diesem Namen, dieser App sieht
kein Mensch an, was sie tut.
Oder was sie für einen tut. Das ist das Problem. Ja Ausweis, ja was.
Das ist ein alter Zonenwitz.
Können Sie sich ausweisen? Wieso kann man das jetzt schon selber?
Haha. Naja, also auf jeden Fall, sie heißt jetzt Ausweis-App.
Schön, super. Sie haben die zwei weggelassen. Ich bin mir sicher,
damit sind alle Probleme in Bezug auf Authentifizierung und Ausweisen in Deutschland
gelöst worden. Es muss nur noch funktionieren.
In die gleiche Bresche schlägt Martin,
also nicht in die Bresche der Appbenamsung, sondern hat eine Frage und zwar
bei der Diskussion um Wallets und Biometrie muss ich auch gleich an Passkeys denken.
Diese Alternative für 2FA wird ja gerade von mehreren Big Tech Konzernen gepusht.
Wollt ihr das eventuell auch mal kurz ansprechen beziehungsweise kritisch betrachten.
Und ja, ich glaube, wir können da mal kurz einen Überblick geben, finde ich.
Weil das ist natürlich definitiv jetzt etwas, was kommt, was jetzt sozusagen neu ist.
Und da hilft es, glaube ich, ein bisschen, die Begriffe auseinander zu halten,
um einfach mal zu wissen, wovon wir hier eigentlich gerade so reden.
Ich kann das, soll ich das erklären? Ich sehe du hast da so einen Chat, GBT Chat verlinkt.
Das war einfach nur, das ist halt das, wie kann man sich besser etwas strukturiert
schnell generieren als damit.
Du kannst das natürlich, war mir schon klar, dass du das jetzt aus dem Kopf machen möchtest.
Ich möchte das aus dem Kopf machen, weil ich nicht.
Weil du nicht irgendwas erzählen möchtest.
Ne, weil ich glaube, dass das hier tatsächlich nicht so gut erklärt ist.
Naja, fand ich schon, aber you may start.
Du hast dann nämlich gefragt, was ist der technische Hintergrund,
das ist das, was ChatGBT als zweites beantwortet, statt es zu Anfang zu erklären.
Also wenn du möchtest, was ist jetzt dein Ansatz? Möchtest du jetzt den Chat vorlesen?
Ich möchte mal kurz Begriffsklärung, nein ich will das nicht alles vorlesen.
Es geht mir um eine Begriffsklärung. Also Authentifizierung,
das ist ja auch so ein beklopptes Wort.
Heißt ja letzten Endes, man soll nachweisen, dass man berechtigt ist,
auf irgendetwas zuzugreifen. Meistens dadurch, dass man...
Dass man klar macht, wer man ist. Und seit Jahrzehnten tun wir das im Netz mit Passwörtern.
Und wir alle wissen, was Passwörter für ein Scheiß sind.
Weil Passwörter heißt, ich muss mir was merken, das kann ich halt auch schnell
vergessen und das kann mir geklaut werden, das kann im Zweifelsfall auch erraten
werden. So Name des Hundes, la la la.
Gibt es ja immer wieder schöne Beispiele, wenn so Reporter auf die Straße gehen,
die Leute zu Passwörtern fragen und so, ja, wie sicher ist denn dein Passwort?
Ja, mein Passwort ist total sicher irgendwie.
Ich habe da mein Hund und mein Geburtsjahr reingenommen. Also ah,
wie heißt denn dein Hund? Ja, wie?
Fifi. Ja und wann bist du geboren? Ja, das heißt 67.
Also, literally, das heißt, wir haben ja auch schon oft hier diese Probleme
mit Phishing besprochen, dass sowas abgegriffen wird.
Man gibt es halt irgendwo ein im guten Glauben, dass man das jetzt eingeben
muss und dann hat man es halt verraten und in dem Moment, wo dieses Wissen geleakt
ist, wo es jemand anders hat,
kann sich halt auch jemand anderes als ich autorisieren und genau das will man
halt nicht oder authentifizieren vielmehr.
Und seit einiger Zeit gibt es halt diese Ergänzung, dass man eben versucht,
die Passwörter dadurch abzusichern, indem man ihnen noch einen zweiten Faktor
hinzufügt. Das kennt ihr alle.
Das sind die Nummern, die man eingeben muss, die einem vorher per SMS zugeschickt werden.
Oder wenn es ein bisschen more sophisticated ist, dann benutzt man eben so ein TOTP App,
also so eine App, die einen immer wieder so Nummernschlüssel generiert,
nachdem sie einmal kryptographisch gefüttert wurde.
Das heißt, eine Webseite oder ein Programm kann einen fragen,
so ok, jetzt guck mal bitte auf diese App, ich hab dir ja mal so einen kryptografischen
Start geliefert und jetzt erzeugt die immer wieder Zahlen und das tut sie alle
30 Sekunden, haut sie eine neue Zahl raus.
Und wenn du mir jetzt die Zahl, die jetzt da gerade generiert wird,
sagst, dann weiß ich, dass das sozusagen auf diesem ursprünglichen Key beruht.
Das ist alles ganz gut, aber das ist halt alles unwieldy, das ist halt alles
irgendwie schwierig und du hast trotzdem immer noch diese Passwörter,
die du immer noch vergessen kannst und die musst du irgendwo speichern und ihr
kennt diesen ganzen Scheiß, geben sie sich ein neues Passwort und dann irgendwie ja,
da muss aber ein Ausrufezeichen und ein lachendes Männchen drin sein,
sonst glauben wir dir nichts und so, also so blöde Regeln oder Passwörter müssen
eine bestimmte Länge haben, okay das kann ich verstehen oder dürfen maximal
nur eine bestimmte Länge haben, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehen kann.
Also mit anderen Worten, Passwörter
sind doof und werden auch durch diese Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
nicht.
So sehr viel besser, dass Leute keine Probleme mehr haben.
Und die fördern halt auch alle so ein bisschen dieses Problem,
dass man eben schnell dann auch irgendwann den Zugriff verliert und dann haben
andere Leute vielleicht den Zugriff man selber nicht.
Und jetzt gibt es halt einen neuen Standard, basiert auf dieser Fido 2.
Spezifikationen, die halt die gute alte Public-Private-Key-Methodik,
die,
wir.
Also generell für starke Verschlüsselung überall verwenden,
auch,
endlich,
zum Einloggen im Web nutzbar macht. Und da sieht es halt so aus,
dass wenn man einmal in seinem Account ist, also sich mal identifiziert hat,
erst mal natürlich wieder mit Passwörtern, also so wie es bisher läuft.
Man legt sich einen neuen Account an und dann sagt man so, okay,
jetzt möchte ich aber auch gerne hier den heißen Scheiß haben.
Und dann kann man sich einen Passkey erzeugen und den erzeugt man natürlich,
wie das eben so ist bei diesem Verfahren, auf dem eigenen Gerät.
Sprich, mein Telefon oder mein Computer würfelt so einen Schlüssel aus und das
ist halt so ein Schlüsselpaar, der so einen privaten und einen öffentlichen Teil hat.
Und der öffentliche Teil, der wird an diese Webseite gegeben,
den privaten, den behält man, den sieht keiner.
Und fortan läuft dann halt das Einloggen eben so, wie man das bei SSH,
die Nerds machen das schon immer so,
Dann sagt die Webseite einfach so, hier hast du irgendeinen random String,
den schicke ich dir jetzt mal rüber, verschlüssel den mal mit deinem privaten
Schlüssel, den nur du hast und dann schickst du mir das Ergebnis.
Das kann man halt mit diesem anderen Schlüsselteil, mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel
überprüfen und dann weiß man das und das geht schneller.
Sieg ist nicht verschlüsseln.
Du signierst den, du verschlüsselst den nicht.
Ja, du signierst den, also du machst eine kryptographische Unterschrift sozusagen
und erzeugst aber so einen Kryptoblob, den du dann halt wieder zurückschickst
und daran kann man dann sehen, so aha,
weil dieses Ergebnis nur mit diesem privaten Schlüssel erzeugt werden konnte,
hast du jetzt nachgewiesen, dass du du bist.
Genau das Schöne ist aber jetzt, jetzt kommt der entscheidende Punkt,
du beweist, dass du den Schlüssel hast, ohne ihn zu verraten.
Das ist ja der entscheidende, der sehr wichtige Unterschied,
der jetzt auch dazu führt, dass es eben nicht ist,
dass du, dass wenn jetzt jemand mitlauschen würde oder so, dass eben potenziell
das Ergebnis, das was du zurückschickst, passt nur zu dieser einen Challenge.
Und wenn die authentifizierende Instanz beim nächsten Mal fragt,
wird sie dir einen anderen Zufallswert geben.
Und das heißt, das, was über die Leitung geht, ist nie das wirkliche Geheimnis.
Das ist ja der große Vorteil dieser Methode.
Genau. Also kurz gesagt, Parski sind eine tolle Sache. Das will man haben.
Und wo ihr die Möglichkeit habt, das zu nutzen, nutzt das.
Gewöhnt euch daran, wie das von eurem Computersystem abgespeichert wird.
Das ist natürlich nichts mehr, was man eintippen kann, ne?
Nee das ist gerätegebunden also das ist halt das wird in der Idee wie Apple sich das so vorstellen.
Ich habe das ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Schritt nach vorne es gefällt mir
sehr viel besser als ein Passwort.
Aber was mir nicht so gut gefällt ist diese Bindung an das Gerät für die jetzt
also bei meinem iPhone Apple sagt ja aber ist ja gar kein Problem.
Machst du einfach iCloud Keychain an und synchst alle deine Passwörter mit unserer
Cloud, dann kannst du Passkeys benutzen und wenn du das nicht machst kannst
du Passkeys nämlich nicht benutzen.
Das bin ich so ein bisschen, bin ich nur so, finde ich nur so halb geil.
Während ich es generell natürlich schön finde, weil die, diese Passkeys dann
an biometrische Authentifizierung binden, also du hast dann im Prinzip,
kannst du dir, also der einfachste Anmeldungsweg wäre, dass du beispielsweise
Face ID hast, um dich bei deinem E-Mail anzumelden.
Und gleichzeitig, selbst wenn der komplette Authentifizierungsvorgang überwacht
wird, eine belauschende Instanz potenziell zumindest nicht das Passwort hat.
Und abgesehen davon, dass das Problem gelöst wird, dass du überall mit dem gleichen
Authentifizierungsvorgang, nämlich hier ist mein Gesicht, ich halte es ans Gerät,
wie sicher auch immer der ist,
reinkommst, während du trotzdem für unterschiedliche Seiten oder unterschiedliche
Authentifizierungsvorgänge immer wieder unterschiedliche Passkeys hast.
Also schon ganz gut.
Genau das ist eine tolle Sache. Ist noch nicht auf allen Webseiten verfügbar.
Die großen haben es hier und da schon umgesetzt.
Amazon hat das. Ich weiß gerade nicht die Liste. Google hat es glaube ich schon.
Also da muss jetzt erstmal die Infrastruktur für gebaut werden und natürlich
muss man auch erstmal gucken, wie die ganze User Experience sich letztlich dann auf die Leute abregnet,
aber mittelfristig wird das
so der Weg sein, mit dem man sich anmeldet und das ist auch ganz gut so.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, dass auf eine Public Private Key,
also für eine Public Private Key Geschichte zu machen, das ist auf jeden Fall
sehr viel sinnvoller und das ist auch irgendwie,
irgendwelche API Tokens und sowas, das es nicht alles gibt, das wäre alles was
irgendwie ein statisches Geheimnis ist,
wenn man schon ohnehin ein statisches Geheimnis vergibt, kann man auch einfach
ein Private Key vergeben und den sicher aufbewahren.
Aber dass diese Technologie jetzt erst kommt, ist auch...
Erkennbar einfach nur damit begründet, dass eben Telefone, Primärtelefone und
natürlich auch relativ viele Laptops jetzt auch, aber durch die Telefone kam
das, dass sie halt ein Secure Enclave haben.
Also im Prinzip eine eingebaute Smartcard, damit du die Dinger auch vor dem
Nutzer verstecken kannst.
Und halt die biometrischen Erkennungssysteme, Kamera und den Fingerabdrucksensor natürlich.
Also könntest du auch ohne biometrische Systeme machen, die Technologie,
kannst du auch ohne alles machen.
Also wie du schon sagtest, SSH macht das seit eh und je mit keybasierter Authentifizierung.
Aber dass man das in die Breite den Leuten geben kann, damit die nämlich nicht
irgendwie den Private Key in das Feld pasten oder sowas, das ist jetzt erst
möglich, weil man genug Endgeräte hat in den Händen der Leute.
Und da hat, also das macht natürlich Sinn, das jetzt auch anzusprechen,
weil über genau das haben wir,
also mehr oder weniger diese technologische Basis, haben wir ja gestern in der
vorangegangenen Folge gesprochen, als es um diese Wallets und sonst was,
was man jetzt alles theoretisch in einen Smartphone werfen kann, gesprochen haben.
Also befürworten wir Passkeys?
Ja, tun wir. Also ich tue das.
Auf jeden Fall besser als Passwörter.
So weiterer Kommentar von Sternburg niedlich, dass Tim zur Untermauerung der
Behauptung, Logbuch-Netzpolitik sei auch in 500 Jahren noch aktuell heranzieht,
dass es dann immer noch den Karneval gebe und nicht die Diskussion um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Guck mal was länger durchhält.
Schwierig, also da weiß ich nicht was ich wetten würde.
Das wird mich heute Nacht noch beschäftigen beim einschlafen.
Vielleicht hilft da auch der nächste Kommentar. Da geht es nämlich um die ganze
Diskussion mit den Zeitreisen. Dazu gab es mehrere Kommentare.
Ich zitiere jetzt mal Dani.
Hallo, folgende Zeitreisen-Option ist für mich die plausibelste.
Es gibt Zeitreisen, Podcasts werden in 500 Jahren noch gehört,
aber wie wir alle anderen auch, die in der Vergangenheit solche Aufrufe gemacht
haben, wurden Linus und Tim besucht, haben aber eingesehen, dass es wichtiger
ist, sich nicht der Welt zu offenbaren.
Siehe auch die Gründe für den vierten Weltkrieg 2190.
Daraufhin antwortet Christian, stimmt nicht ganz. Es ist mehr wie die Terminator-Reihe.
Kaum hat einer das Signal in die Vergangenheit gesendet, kommt ihm einer zuvor,
der ihn liquidiert. Der nächste bringt das Signal dann eine Episode früher.
Aber irgendwann wird der Stegosaurus mit dem LNP Arschgeweih ausgebuddelt und
dann erfahren alle die Wahrheit, warum die Dinosaurier wirklich ausgestorben sind.
Das lassen wir mal so stehen.
So wird es sein.
So, der nächste Kommentar ist besonders lustig, weil er sich auf die Funny Germans bezieht.
Von Andreas.
Hab mich sehr über den Dank von Thomas gefreut und über den herrlichen Sendungstitel.
Kleine Korrektur, Clarissas Bezeichnung lautet Giggling Germans.
Aber ab und zu übersetze ich ihr was, was ich beim Hören lache und sie stimmt
auch schon mal zu, dass ihr lustig seid. Sehr schön. Grüße aus New York.
Giggling Germans. Eine Alliteration. Der wird immer besser für uns hier.
Ist Giggling Germans wirklich eine Alliteration?
Ja.
Also es ist eine echte Alliteration, naja, aber es spricht sich ja nicht… The
Juggling Giggling Germans. Also Alliteration meint zwar vom Wortsinne her,
dass es phonetisch sein oder?
Naja aber ich finde es funktioniert halt nur wenn es phonetisch identisch ist.
Also insofern ist Alliteration eigentlich eine falsche Bezeichnung,
weil es ja darum geht, dass es sich gleich ausspricht.
Jiggling Germans, oder Giggling Gurmans, was auch nicht so richtig klingt.
Siegigi, The Giggling Gurmans, The Giggling Germs.
Ich stand ja auch vor der Herausforderung, den Titel Deutsch,
aber lustig, in ein Episodenbild umzusetzen.
Oh, hab ich mir gar nicht mehr angeguckt. Ach doch, das ist dir gelungen? Wiegen?
Aber das ist ganz klar erkennbar beeinflusst vom 100-jährigen Geburtstag von Viko von Bülow.
Ich freue mich ja, wenn das jemand gemerkt hat. Wir haben es ja leider...
Leider vergessen nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, weil das wirklich jetzt auch genau am 100.
Geburtstag oder dem theoretischen 100. Geburtstag von Loriot gewesen ist und
ich dachte mir dann es gibt nur einen einzigen witzigen Deutschen,
der wirklich zweifellos witzig war.
Es gibt nur einen witzigen Deutschen und einen Rudi Völler.
Es gibt nur einen Rudi Völler und es gab nur einen wirklich witzigen Deutschen
und das war einfach Loriot.
Sorry, aber alles was… Es gibt nur einen witzigen Deutschen.
Ich lasse noch mit Heinz R.
Mit mir reden, aber nach Loriot ging es eigentlich nur noch bergab.
Also Otto hatte so eine kurze Phase und danach war es eigentlich vorbei und
seitdem konnte ich ehrlich gesagt kaum noch über irgendwas lachen.
Und ich lache heute immer noch sehr gerne über Luriau, weil ich finde,
dass seine Betrachtung der Zeit war einfach treffend.
Wobei es schwierig ist, habe ich gemerkt, jüngeren Menschen,
ihr wisst schon, wen ich meine,
diesen Humor zu erklären, weil der natürlich vor allem nur dann funktioniert,
wenn man ihn sozusagen in der Zeit resonieren lässt.
Und das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, Leuten noch zu vermitteln,
wie Deutschland so war Ende der 70er Jahre.
Und vielleicht auch noch so in den 80er Jahren, weil das, worüber er sich lustig
gemacht hat, natürlich dann sehr viel stärker war.
Aber in gewisser Hinsicht ist es halt immer noch top aktuell.
Also ich meine, das Jodel-Diplom, das kannst du dir heute noch anschauen und,
da ist einfach die ganze Frauenrechtsdebatte.
Immer noch voll dabei, ja. Also es ist einfach, sagt einfach alles aus.
Ich habe da noch versucht, ein Bild zu generieren, wo er nicht alleine auf dem
Sofa sitzt, sondern dieses großartige Bild mit Evelyn Harman,
seiner kongenialen Partnerin, die zusammen einfach,
also Lorio war ja alleine schon witzig, aber Evelyn Harman und Lorio zusammen, das war einfach mega.
Und wie die beiden da auf dem Bild hocken irgendwie und in die Kamera schauen,
das ist, ich hab also Stunden damit verbracht irgendwie Che Che Petit zu beschreiben was irgendwie,
was das ausmacht und es ist mir einfach nicht gelungen irgendein Bild zu erzeugen
was auch nur ansatzweise das macht und deswegen bin ich bei diesem einen Bild
dann hängen geblieben, was so in etwa war. Aber viele Leute haben es trotzdem verstanden.
Naja, jetzt habe ich mich geoutet als Lorio-Fan.
Aber tatsächlich, das ist erstaunlich, weil sie ja wirklich,
sie waren in vielen der Sketches dabei, also in allen Sendungen mehr oder weniger,
aber weil er der Namensgebende war.
Ist dann Loriot, alles was Loriot ist, bezieht sich dann doch erstmal wieder auf ihn.
Es waren ja noch ein paar andere großartige Schauspieler mit dabei,
die regelmäßig dazu beigetragen haben, aber es ist ja auch letzten Endes alles
aus seinem Mist gewachsen.
Aber ich möchte ja immer noch, ich hab während du gerade sprachst von den witzigsten
Deutschen, hab ich mal die witzigsten Deutschen gegoogelt und Google meinte
so ungefähr so, also die Antwort von Google, die witzigsten Deutschen was denn?
Ich verstehe die Frage nicht.
Serien, Phänomene, Kriege.
Was sind denn die witzigsten Deutschen Kriege so?
Aber ich hatte Deutschen schon groß geschrieben und dann habe ich gedacht,
okay ich muss zu Chetjipiti gehen und Chetjipiti, habe ich gesagt,
wer sind die witzigsten Deutschen, das ist Chetjipiti, ja,
Humor subjektiv schwer zu sagen, wer die witzigsten Deutschen sind,
persönliche Vorlieben, aber es gibt so ein paar, da muss man eigentlich schon
sagen, einige Beispiele könnten sein.
Norio, Otto Walkes, Anke Engelke, Michael-Bulli Herbig und Habe Kerkeling.
Aber da gibt es auch viele andere, musst du gucken und so.
Und dann habe ich einfach nur gesagt, Moment mal, warum kriege ich eigentlich nur fünf?
Weil normalerweise, wenn du Chechi mit dir was fragst, machst du ja schon zehn.
Also habe ich gesagt, kannst du zehn machen?
Sagt er, okay, das ist auch so, dann fängt er schon an so Einschränkungen zu
machen, so, naja, okay, also hier sind zehn Komiker, die für ihren Humor bekannt sind.
Zehn deutsche Komiker, die für ihren Humor bekannt sind.
Nicht wie die anderen, die für irgendwas anderes bekannt sind.
Aber, ich sag mal, also man muss dann JetGPT, das ist jetzt hier GPT in der
Version 3.5, schon direkt zur Last legen, dass es dann anfängt zu,
halluzinieren, ja, also erkennbar ist das Ding da am Ende.
Es macht nämlich weiter mit Dieter Nuhr und da habe ich auch gedacht,
okay, das Ding ist jetzt völlig in der Illusion, ja.
Atze Schröder, Oliver Kalkofe, Ingo Appelt und Bülent Ceylan.
Also klar im absoluten Delirium nach fünf deutschen Komikern,
die für ihren Humor bekannt sind.
Also bei bei bei Harpe Kerkling gehe ich ja noch mit.
Ja, jetzt habe ich mal gesagt, was ist denn mit Frauen?
Ja, da kenne ich auch nur Karolin Kebekus. Und jetzt ist auf einmal Anke Engelke nicht mehr in der Liste.
Also da bin ich jetzt nicht nicht überzeugt. Die anderen kenne ich alle gar nicht.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall auch totaler...
Und Carolin Kebekus Ultra, also da geh ich auch mit.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht wirklich sagen, dass niemand mehr witzig ist,
aber ich finde das L'Oreal hat einfach gut abgeräumt.
Was wirklich interessant ist, er hat ja auch in den 70ern all seine großen Werke,
all diese ganzen Fernsehsendungen, die er da gemacht hat, mit denen er so bekannt geworden ist.
Und dieses ganze sonstige Schaffen noch drumherum, auch diese Comiczeichnen,
Wummen und Wendelin und diese ganzen Sachen, das ist ja alles innerhalb von
wenigen Jahren Ende der 70er Jahre entstanden, der zweiten Hälfte der 70er Jahre.
Und danach war eigentlich schon wieder Ruhe. Er hat dann später noch Filme gemacht.
Ja, aber es war irgendwie alles gesagt. Also er hat einfach in einer ganz kurzen
Schaffenszeit alles rausgehauen.
Und das sind alles epische Werke und das kann man sich noch jahrzehntelang anschauen.
Und auch bei uns ist auch irgendwie so in der Familie,
Weihnachten ist einfach ohne Familie Hoppenstädt und das Weihnachtsgedicht und
so weiter nicht zu denken und es wird immer so sein.
Und weißt du, wer noch genau zu dieser Zeit ein Großwerk der Komikerkunst in die Welt gelassen hat?
Und es im Wesentlichen auch in diesem kurzen Zeitraum getan hat und danach erstmal
eine ganze Weile lang nicht mehr?
Nee.
Monty Pythons Flying Circus. Und das war mehr oder weniger zeitgleich und auch
die haben so innerhalb von ein paar Jahren im Fernsehen alles rausgehauen.
Also das ist irre, ne? Die 70er Jahre, wer hätte sie im Verdacht gehabt?
Aber da waren echt die Großwerke der Humorkunst am Start.
Und danach wurde es ein bisschen schwierig.
Ah ok, ich hab jetzt direkt gefragt, wer sind denn die witzigsten der Welt.
Da gibt's 10.
Charlie Chaplin, Richard Pryor, den kennt in Deutschland glaube ich kaum jemand,
aber der hat eigentlich die Stand-up-Comedy definiert.
Und auch also den der Richard Pryor ist schon richtig geil Lucille Ball,
in der Sitcom I love Lucy, dann kommt Monty Python, dann kommt Rowan Atkinson, kannte als Mr. Bean,
Tina Fey von Saturday Night Live,
Eddie Izzard, Robin Williams, den hätte man weiter oben einsortieren dürfen,
Da kommst du glaube ich nicht so richtig weit. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Aber ich war beeindruckt, dass Richard Pryor gewürdigt wurde.
Also wenn ihr alle Namen noch nie gehört habt, dann fangt am besten mal mit.
Lorio und mit Monty Python an.
Das braucht sowieso an keiner Diskussion teilzunehmen, wenn ihr mit dem Werken
nicht vertraut seid. Gut, soviel zu unserer deutschen Analyse von Humor,
dass wir das mal festgehalten wurden.
Die Regeln haben wir jetzt auch schon mal festgezurrt.
Genau. So, damit haben wir unseren Feedback-Blog dann auch schon nach einer
Stunde verlassen und Wir kommen auf ja ein anderes Geschehen,
was die letzten Tage und eigentlich auch immer noch heftig die Runde macht.
Ich weiß nicht, vor einer Woche gab es von OpenAI, das haben wir soviel über
ChatGPT schon schwadroniert, OpenAI, die Firma, die ChatGPT macht,
hat vor einer Woche so eine Keynote gemacht.
Und das war sozusagen so ein bisschen so die Keynote des Jahres,
die kommt ja nicht mehr von Apple.
Ich weiß nicht ob du es gesehen hast, aber damit haben sie ja.
Die haben eben Bomben Laptops da hergestellt, eins allein ab,
hier Aktie hoch, alles gut.
Ja, aber das ist ja alles dasselbe in grün, also das ist ja sozusagen nichts revolutionäres.
Und abgesehen davon ist Apple nun gerade in diesem Bereich, der gerade heiß
ist, wirklich komplett abgemeldet.
Ja ein bisschen schwach ist gut gesagt, scheiße stehen sie da.
Also da werden sie, da haben sie sich einen strategischen Fehler geleistet.
Naja, also OpenAI steht auf jeden Fall im Mittelpunkt und dann haben sie halt
diese Kino draus gehauen und das war dann schon so ein Statement.
Das war so, ja wir drehen jetzt mal so richtig auf und jetzt gibt's hier irgendwie
Chat-GPT-4 in der Turbo-Version und so weiter, ne, mit irgendwie,
kannst dich noch mehr merken, kannst dir noch die kompletten Bücher reinkloppen.
Und dann darüber AI machen. Also das wird wirklich Auswirkungen haben und sie
haben irgendwie ihre API verbessert und dann alles billiger und pipapo.
Also das waren wirklich so Announcements und alle so, boah krass,
hier geht's ja richtig zur Sache.
Und dann ein paar Tage später, ah ja, Sam Altman, also der CEO,
der auch diese Präsentation gemacht hat, im Übrigen unter anderem hatte er als
Gast noch, es hat ja Nadella, den Chef von Microsoft, mit auf der Bühne.
Die sich gegenseitig belobhubelt haben, wie toll sie sich finden und wie sehr
sie gemeinsam in den Sonnenuntergang schreiten und ein paar Tage später kam dann die Meldung,
ja der CEO Sam Altman ist entlassen. Also wie was?
Ja das Board hat sich irgendwie getroffen und hat irgendwie beschlossen ihn zu entlassen. Grund?
Ja irgendwas mit Vertrauen nicht gegeben.
Das war das Statement.
Also hat er sich nicht benommen oder so? Hat er irgendwas gemacht?
Keiner weiß, es gibt nur Vermutungen darüber, was er vielleicht getan hat oder nicht getan hat.
Es gibt die Vermutung, dass er daran arbeitet, eine neue Firma aufzubauen nebenbei.
Es ist, also da kann ich mich jetzt überhaupt nicht konkret zu äußern,
weil ich glaube, dass man das derzeit noch nicht weiß.
Die Gerüchteküche ist groß und das Ganze hat viele Nuancen. Jetzt ist ja so,
also OpenAI ist so eine zweigeteilte Firma oder beziehungsweise es gibt das OpenAI Inc.
Und es gibt ein OpenAI Global LLC, also es gibt sozusagen einen Non-Profit-Container,
der,
die eigentliche Firma ist, wovon Altman auch CEO war und unter anderem gehört,
diesem OpenAI Inc. auch eine For-Profit-Firma,
die halt die ganzen Produkte und so weiter macht und Lizenzen verkauft etc.
Aber das Ding ist, dass OpenAI eigentlich gegründet wurde 2015,
also jetzt ziemlich genau vor acht Jahren,
als Ort des Researches und der sollte halt auch offen für die Welt sein und
das Ganze ebenso als Non-Profit.
Was schon sehr ungewöhnlich war.
Unter anderem gehörten zu diesen Gründern auch Sam Altman, aber auch Elon Musk
und der Peter Thiel, also die dann sozusagen auch initial da Kohle reingeworfen haben.
Die haben dann im weiteren nicht mehr so richtig viel mit dem Laden zu tun gehabt,
außer nämlich Sam Altman, der dann zunächst im Board war und später dann eben auch CEO wurde.
Ja und der Laden hat also innerhalb kürzester Zeit sehr viel Talent akquiriert.
2018 ist dann Elon Musk raus aus dem Board, wegen potenzieller Konflikte,
sieht man ja jetzt. Jetzt hat er mit Tesla selber eine AI-Bude gestartet und,
bis dahin war der ganze Laden noch so ein bisschen unter dem Radar.
Und 2019, da habe ich auch das erste Mal davon gehört, kam halt dieses GPT-2,
raus, also ihr Transformer-Modell in der zweiten Version und das hat halt schon
alle total umgehauen, weil das eben in der Lage war, diese Texte zu erzeugen.
Also da konnte man das erste Mal generiert Text machen, der irgendwie nicht
so robothaft klang, sondern eben einfach klang wie, naja, so wie man da jetzt
heute mit kommuniziert.
Später haben sie dann auch dieses Non-Profit-Ding ein bisschen geändert in der
Konstruktion und haben gesagt, ja ne, wir können schon Profit machen,
aber wir haben ein Profit-Cap und das Profit-Cap ist irgendwie das 100-fache vom Investment,
also bei.
Dem,
hohen,
Investment, was da kam, bleibt da genug Profit,
glaube ich,
über.
Das ist mir alles noch so ein bisschen unklar, wie das da wirklich gelebt und
gefühlt wird, aber das ist zumindest die offizielle Darstellung.
Dann kam sie 2020.
Mit GPT 3 raus und das ist schon dieses erste System, dem man so Fragen stellen konnte.
Und was in der Lage war Texte zu übersetzen und was als erstes auch so eine
API hatte, das ist auch noch so ein bisschen im.
Noch nicht so richtig in den News durchgedrungen, aber das hatte eben schon
im Research-Bereich eine ganze Menge Welle gemacht.
Also GPT-3, da haben alle schon kräftig durchgeatmet, da hat man schon gemerkt,
so okay, dieser Laden, der ist an was dran, da kommt was bei raus, die.
Sind einen Schritt weiter. Spätestens zu diesem Zeitpunkt hätte Apple mal anfangen
sollen, die Zeichen der Zeit richtig zu lesen. Haben sie aber nicht.
Also wurden sie überrollt. Dann kam 2021 dieses Dolly raus, was ja diese Bilder erzeugen kann.
Das war ja dann schon ein ziemlicher Hammer. Und dann eben, was wir nun alle
mitbekommen haben, genau vor einem Jahr, Dezember 2022, eben Chat GPT.
Also jetzt konnte man eben mit diesem GPT auch richtig im Dialog reden und das
ist ja im Prinzip die alte Erfüllung des KI-Traums,
damals mit Josef Weizenbaums Eliza, war das ja eigentlich genau die Idee,
so ein Chat zu machen, wo die Leute gucken sollten, bist du eine richtige Maschine?
Damals, Eliza war ja so ein bisschen gehackt, immer wenn eine konkrete Nachfrage
kam, wurde dann so eine Gegenfrage gestellt. Warum denkst du das?
Und so. Genau. Und dann jetzt im März halt GPT 4 und so.
Was jetzt also wirklich passiert, wir wissen es nicht. Konkret,
vielleicht erstmal was so passiert ist. Dieses Board hat ein Meeting gemacht
und hat gesagt, du fliegst jetzt raus als CEO.
Keiner wusste was davon, alles war nur short notice.
Und auch der, ich weiß seinen Vornamen nicht, Brockman, der war der Chairman
dieses Boards, der wurde auch als Chairman abgesetzt.
Muss man wissen, dass Brockman und Altman also gut miteinander konnten,
der Brockman hat danach auch gleich gekündigt.
Und dann war natürlich die Aufregung groß und weil natürlich alle so wie was
hier, ich dachte das ist euer neuer Superstar, wieso schmeißt ihr den raus?
Und seitdem geht's wild her, insbesondere bei der Belegschaft von OpenAI,
die wohl alle dem Board gesagt haben, was macht ihr da, habt ihr noch eine Meise?
Und mittlerweile gibt es also einerseits die Androhung von massenhaften Austritten
und wohl auch schon diverse Kündigungen.
Dann ist der Druck aufs Board wohl so schnell so groß geworden,
dass die im Prinzip zurückgezogen haben, aber die Entscheidung war ja im Prinzip
schon gefallen, also die Kündigung war schon ausgesprochen.
Dann hieß es ein, zwei Tage im Nachrichtenflow, sie probieren jetzt alles,
um ihn wieder zurückzuholen,
weil sie halt so viel Androhung bekommen hatten von Top Talent,
was halt gehen will, wenn Sam Altman geht, weil was soll das?
Und die letzte Note in dieser Melodie ist, dass Microsoft,
die ja schwere Investoren in diesen Laden sind, einerseits und andererseits
sich auch technologisch schon sehr an Chet GPT gebunden haben,
durch irgendwie Office 365 etc. Radhausen und andere Sachen.
Die ganze Infrastruktur, Azure ist sozusagen das, was die technische Basis ist von GPT.
Und ja, der hat schnell geschaltet und hat gesagt, okay den müssen wir binden
und jetzt arbeitet er für Microsoft.
Bäm. So, Rückkehr zu OpenAI ist sozusagen vom Tisch und jetzt kann es sehr gut sein,
dass wir in den nächsten Tagen ein Exodus sehen werden von den Top Leuten von
OpenAI zu Microsoft und dass quasi OpenAI mehr oder weniger in Microsoft aufgeht.
Könnte ich mir fast vorstellen, weil das ist, das ist also.
Wie kann man sich denn so verzocken?
Genau, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage warum.
Ja, aber die haben, also alles was ich gelesen habe war, dass sie sagten,
der wäre irgendwie nicht ehrlich zu ihnen gewesen.
Ja, das war halt so diese Aussage. Was man jetzt wohl,
was kolportiert wird ist, dass vor allem ein weiteres Gründungsmitglied von
OpenAI, ein sogenannter Ilya Sudzkiva,
dahinter steht und dass der quasi so ein Ding mit dem Sam Altman am Laufen hat,
weil er auch ein starker Verfechter dieser Non-Profit-Idee ist.
Und dass der ganze Weg, den Open AI jetzt eingeschlagen hat mit diesen ganzen
Business Partnerschaften und den Produkten, die sie gemacht haben, ihm nicht gepasst hat.
Oder einer Gruppe von Leuten nicht gepasst hat, die er im Wesentlichen repräsentiert.
Wie gesagt, das ist alles noch grain of salt.
Kann sein, dass die nächste Woche die Situation sich schon wieder ganz anders
darstellt. Aber das ist so das, was die Gerüchteküche derzeit sagt.
Dass er eigentlich so ein bisschen derjenige ist, der das restliche Board davon
überzeugt hat, hier entsprechend diese Entscheidungen zu fällen.
Aber ich glaube, dass mittlerweile, ja, dass sich die Leute anders überlegen
würden, wenn sie jetzt gewusst hätten, was dabei hinten rauskommt.
Kann man sich eigentlich auch an einem an einer Hand abzählen,
dieser Sam Altman ist in den letzten Monaten schon so zu einem,
wie soll man das sagen, also auf jeden Fall zu einem Sprachrohr der ganzen Tech-Szene geworden,
also nicht dem einzigen Sprachrohr, sondern einer Person, der man so zuhört,
so wie man die Jahre zuvor viel zu sehr Elon Musk bei seinen Halluzinationen zugehört hat.
Ja, wenn sich ein Jeff Bezos, was er ja immerhin selten tut,
aber wenn er sich mal äußert, dann wird er zugehört.
Und auch ein Tim Cook hat hier natürlich was zu sagen, wie auch ein Satya Nadella.
Aber jetzt ist sozusagen mit diesem kleinen Mini-Startup OpenAI einfach nochmal
ein Player mit reingekommen, den
so vor einem Jahr viele noch nicht mal so richtig auf dem Zettel hatten.
Und dieser Superstar, der vor allem in der Lage ist, ganze Sätze zu bilden und
nicht so total hyperventilierend rüberkommt.
Also ich weiß jetzt auch nicht genau, ich kann diesen Typen ehrlich gesagt noch
null einschätzen und kann auch gut sein,
dass wir da auch noch die dunkle Seite erkennen, aber zumindest war er in seinem
ganzen Auftreten erstmal sehr viel konsumierbarer als viele andere,
die schon völlig durchgedreht sind.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen die Situation.
Das ist bemerkenswert, was da passiert.
Ich weiß jetzt noch nicht so ganz genau, was am Ende der interessante Teil sein
wird, ob hier irgendwie ein Non-Profit Modell gescheitert ist oder ob einfach wir nur feststellen,
dass dieser ganze AI Bereich so ein Haifischbecken geworden ist in so kurzer
Zeit, dass es hier die ganze Business,
Landschaft komplett auf den Kopf stellt. Das wird sich noch zeigen.
Also auf jeden Fall eine faszinierende Situation.
Kann keiner nachvollziehen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, dieser Vorstand der stand auf jeden Fall ein bisschen doof
da und so nach dem Motto, ja was denn das ist doch nur eine Fleischwunde.
Spuckt dir ins Laufgerät und blendet dich.
So viel zu multiplen und seinem Einfluss.
Ich bin gespannt, also ich meine, ich bin, ich fühle mich schon wieder so ein
bisschen schlecht, jetzt haben wir so viel über Chachipiti geredet und so weiter
und das ist halt einfach, das ist eine faszinierende Technologie.
Es kann ja sehr gut sein, dass wir hier in fünf Jahren sitzen und auf diese
Zeit zurückblicken und denken, Alter, was waren wir ja. Weißt du noch AI?
Weißt du noch Fetz die Pistole? Fünf AI!
Fünf!
Aber glaube ich aber nicht. Also das ist definitiv was anderes als Blockchain.
Nur, also ich weiß nicht genau wie wir dann diese Unternehmung und diese Personen
bewerten werden, die jetzt hier neu auf die Bühne getreten sind.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass sich da alle als Weirdos herausstellen.
Kann natürlich auch anders laufen, wir wissen es nicht.
Und insofern ist es ganz spannend. Aber es zeigt eben auch, wie transformativ das ist.
Und wie transformativ Technologie an sich ist.
Schritt, der sich jetzt durch diese Technologie zeigt,
der hat einfach das Potenzial, die gesamte Business Welt, die gesamte Business
Landschaft wieder komplett neu zu justieren.
Das starke schwächer werden und so weiter.
Also Apple ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Also die sind da jetzt wirklich gefordert da in irgendeiner Form mitzuhalten,
weil es einfach absehbar ist.
Also nicht so, dass sie da jetzt keinerlei, keine Stakes drin haben,
aber sie sind definitiv nicht der Technologieführer.
Und ich glaube das hat auch viel mit ihrer Firmenkultur zu tun,
dass sie gar nicht in der Lage waren so ein Projekt wie das Open AI war aufzuziehen.
Weil ich glaube, dass diese Offenheit und vielleicht auch dieser Non-Profit-Aspekt,
dabei schon geholfen hat, weil es liest sich so ein bisschen,
wenn man ein bisschen die Vergangenheit von der Firma reinliest.
Viele, also sie haben wirklich die Top-Talente aus diesem AI-Bereich oder sehr
viele Top-Talente aus diesem AI-Bereich dort versammelt und,
viele haben auch sich,
entschieden.
Dort,
zu
arbeiten,
obwohl,
sie,
von,
anderen Stellen,
teilweise,
so
abstrus,
übertriebene,
andere,
Angebote,
hatten,
die,
also das Finanzielle nochmal,
bei,
Weitem,
überstiegen,
hätten, was sie dort,
bei,
Open,
AI
bekommen haben. Trotzdem haben sich viele dem angeschlossen,
weil es einfach so ein bisschen der Ort war, wo alle so das Gefühl hatten,
hier passiert das nächste große Ding und genau das ist ja am Ende auch passiert.
Also, ich bin wirklich gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr schön, dass sie sich direkt am Anfang verzoffen
und dann von Microsoft irgendwie die Lichtgestalt aufgezogen wird.
Das bin ich mal gespannt, ob da noch einige Leute das...
Also als dieser ganze AI-Kram so ungefähr vor einem Jahr losging,
als dann viele meinten, sie hat die Zukunft gehört dann, den Open Source Modellen und so,
das werden wir alles selber entwickeln, dann werden wir richtig geil,
dann machen wir alle, trainieren wir unsere Modelle und so, das war ja etwas,
wo ich ohne besondere Kenntnis der Technologie erst mal skeptisch war,
aus reiner kapitalistischer Erfahrung.
Dass solche Technologien am Ende dann doch eher in den Händen des großen Geldes landen.
Da sehe ich jetzt auf jeden Fall einen Schritt in diese Richtung.
Da sehe ich jetzt also keinen Schritt in die...
Demokratisierung dieser Technologie gerade, wenn da das Open AI Ding zerlegt
wird und der CEO die Lichtgestalt zu Microsoft geht.
Also habe ich auf jeden Fall schon vorher auch schon mal so in der Form gesehen.
Also dieser Ilja Sutzkever ist natürlich auch ein sehr interessanter Mensch,
also nicht nur, dass er den Laden mit gegründet hat, sondern er gehört ja auch
zu denen, Also er gehört auch wirklich zu den Leuten, die dieses ganze Deep
Learning vorangebracht haben.
Also auch zusammen da mit diesem Geoffrey hinten sozusagen an den ganz entscheidenden
Sachen mitgearbeitet, auch das AlphaGo, was wir hier schon besprochen haben,
da gehört er zu den Co-Autoren.
Also und der war halt der oder ist noch der Chief of Science sozusagen.
Also der ist sozusagen jetzt nicht nur irgendwie so ein Board Member,
sondern der ist der Head of Science, der Wissenschaftschef quasi bei Open AI gewesen.
Und das ist halt jetzt wirklich irre, ne. Also dass in diesem Laden jetzt da
so eine Trennung durchgezogen wird von Pro und Contra, Sam Altman,
was auch immer da letzten Endes jetzt der Auslöser war.
Und es sieht also sehr danach aus, dass Microsoft demnächst ein paar ridiculously
paid neue Mitarbeiter bekommt, die sie aber mit Kusshand, glaube ich, nicht nehmen.
Okay, dann kommen wir mal zu weiteren unterhaltsamen Nachrichten aus Deutschland.
Wir haben uns ja jetzt schon unsere Schwierigkeiten besprochen,
fünf deutsche Komiker zu finden, die sich durch Humor auszeichnen.
Nachrichten gibt es aus dem Infrastrukturausbau in Deutschland und zwar sind
das eigentlich zwei Meldungen, die ich hier sehr spannend finde.
Also wir haben eine Mobilfunkinfrastrukturgesellschaft des Bundes seit drei
Jahren und die war drei Jahre tätig und kann jetzt etwas feiern,
weil sie zum ersten Mal gleich mit zwei Projekten die komplette Förderkette durchlaufen hat.
Also die haben nur drei Jahre gebraucht, um de facto zwei Mobilfunkantennen jetzt zu bauen.
Was? Wirklich?
Zwei? Und das ist ein Scheuer-Projekt, insofern ist das irre,
dass die überhaupt was hingekriegt haben.
Also vom damaligen Minister für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur Andreas Scheuer.
Hat etwas länger gebraucht als ursprünglich vorgesehen, aber immerhin war es
nicht wie jetzt so eine Mautgeschichte oder so völlig ergebnislos und nur mit Strafen verbunden,
sondern die haben also jetzt eine dreijährige Planungszeit durchlaufen.
Damit bauen sie jetzt in der Gemeinde Markt lahm.
Oder ich weiß nicht ganz klar, ob die Gemeinde Markt-Lahm heißt oder ob Lahm
der erste Vorname des Bürgermeisters ist.
Aber wahrscheinlich heißt die Gemeinde Markt-Lahm und der Bürgermeister Peter Roosberger.
Und der freut sich jetzt auf den Turm, der wird von der Deutschen Funkturm Management GmbH gebaut.
Das ist die Mastbetreibergesellschaft der Deutschen Telekom,
ausgegründet natürlich.
Die haben mehrere zehntausend Standorte, beispielsweise auf Fernsehtürmen und so.
Allerdings nicht zu früh, weil das kann jetzt nicht sofort in Betrieb gehen,
da fehlen noch die Antennen und der Strom.
Aber die haben jetzt da wahrscheinlich einen Mast gebaut.
Und das ist doch schon mal feierlich, das ist doch schön, da können wir uns doch freuen.
Und in Möhnesee im Landkreis Soest wird auch ein Mast gebaut.
Das ist an der Möhne-Talsperre und da fahren gerne mal Leute aus dem Ruhrgebiet
hin. Die haben dann da auch bald Empfang.
Da wird dann von Vantage Towers, das ist die Maßausgründung von Vodafone eine
Antenne in Betrieb genommen.
Und die haben aber dann, die MEG hat eine Markenerkundung gemacht und da haben
sie insgesamt 1300 Standorte.
Also sie haben an 1700 Standorten sich umgeschaut, dann blieben 1300 über und
für 50 von diesen 1300 Standorten, wo man mal was machen müsste,
wurde dann die Förderfähigkeit festgestellt.
Bürokratie ist so ein Traum, ja.
Also das ist natürlich irre, dass da dann bald irgendwann mal Empfang sein wird.
Da muss man jetzt nur noch Strom hinlegen, wo man seit drei Jahren einen Turm
plant, um eine Antenne hinzubauen. Als nächstes muss man vielleicht feststellen,
dass man da noch Internet hinlegen müsste.
Aber das wird schon. Das wird. Ja. Und,
In other news hat die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt mit Bußgeldverfahren gegen Deutsche
Telekom, Telefonica und Vodafone quasi Verfahren eingeleitet,
wegen schuldhafter, nicht rechtzeitiger, vollständiger Erfüllung der Versorgungsauflagen,
weil es halt keinen Empfang gibt.
Allerdings meinen die Betreiber, sie hätten nicht gegen die Ausbauauflagen verstoßen
und berufen sich auf eine Ausnahmeregel,
denn wo der Ausbau aus rechtlichen Gründen nicht möglich war,
etwa weil niemand ein Grundstück vermieten wollte,
auf dem ein Funkmast aufgestellt werden kann,
gilt die Auflage, also auch ohne, dass es da ein Netz gibt, eben als erfüllt. Sie haben es versucht.
Wir haben einfach keinen gefunden, dass wir hier was hinbauen dürfen,
das ist doch wirklich geil, wenn du sowas liest, also die wollen,
die kippen da schon Geld rein,
wir müssen mit Bußgeld gegen die Netze vorgehen und die sagen also ey man wir wollen,
aber irgendwo sitzt irgendein Wavy und der möchte nicht, dass wir die Antenne
da hinbauen, das ist schon.
Deutschland hätte einfach selber ausbauen sollen und das einfach untervermieten,
das wäre das Beste gewesen.
Ich, was würdest du dazu noch sagen? Du guckst dir das an und denkst dir halt echt so,
wenn der Titel nicht schon weg wäre, wüsste ich was Deutschland gerade macht.
Aber es ist doch wirklich zum heulen, oder?
Ja, es ist einfach Pritt Love's Law.
Pritt Love's Law? Oh, jetzt wird's aber richtig wild.
Naja, es ist einfach mein Gesetz, mit dem man berechnen kann,
wann Deutschland den Einstieg in das digitale Zeitalter schafft.
Und wie ist das? Wie geht Pritt Love's Law?
Nein, das wird nix.
Mit Fortschreiten der Digitalisierung nähert sich die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass Deutschland Mittwoch null an.
Das ist ein Brillensloch.
Das wird nichts mehr. Das kann man vergessen. Mal gucken.
Vielleicht hat Deutschland wieder eine Chance mit irgendwas,
was nach der Digitalisierung kommt. Dann können wir da vielleicht wieder mitmachen.
Aber ich glaube, der Zug ist abgefahren.
Wir haben es in der letzten Sendung schon behandelt.
Ich will es eigentlich nur noch mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen,
wie die Lage bei der Chat-Kontrolle ist.
Der Liebeausschuss hat für den Kompromiss gestimmt.
Im Rat bleibt es unverändert.
Also da ist die Stimmung noch nicht entschieden. Was jetzt interessant ist,
ist, dass das Europaparlament hat jetzt das direkte Verhandlungsmandat im Trilog.
Das heißt, das Europaparlament wird darüber informiert, dass der Ausschuss direkt
mit dem Text in den Trilog eintreten möchte, ohne weitere Abstimmung im Europaparlament.
Das Europaparlament kann dann entsprechen, macht es aber nicht.
Und damit geht es dann bald in den Trilog.
Das möchte ich nur noch mal so zur Lage zusammenfassen.
Wir haben den Kompromiss ja ausführlich schon mal behandelt.
Thomas hat es in der letzten Sendung auch noch mal gemacht.
Das aber nur zur Lage und eigentlich eher als Einführung kurz zum nächsten Thema. Denn...
Wir erinnern uns, wir haben es ja auch öfter schon besprochen,
dass es ja eine Verschärfung der Gesetzeslage gab,
was die Verbreitung von sogenannter Kinderpornografie betrifft.
Ich sage das jetzt spezifisch mal diesem Begriff, weil es war ja der,
wir sprechen ja häufig von dokumentiertem Kindesmissbrauch, ja,
und dann gab es aber den Gesetzesentwurf, damals zur Verschärfung des Sexualstrafrechts,
der folgendes zur Folge hatte.
Wenn du guckst beim BKA, im Lagebild zu Sexualdelikten zum Nachteil von Kindern, dann wurden 17.549,
von insgesamt 42.000 Tatverdächtigen.
Waren,
nicht volljährig, also über 40 Prozent.
Das sind also die sogenannten Selbstfilmer, die also in den Rahmen dieses Gesetzes
fallen und weil es dort eine Mindeststrafe von einem Jahr gibt und damit eben ein,
weil es ein schweres, damit wird es ein schweres Vergehen und dann haben die
Ermittler keine Wahl mehr und müssen jeden noch so kleinen Fall vor Gericht bringen.
Und das sind dann die sogenannten Schulhoffälle, wo also junge Mädchen oder
Jungen Nacktfotos von sich machen und die jemandem schicken oder diese Fotos
dann untereinander geteilt werden,
ohne dass man sich der Strafbarkeit bewusst ist.
Da möchte also jetzt unser Justizminister Marco Buschmann den relevanten Paragraphen
184 Bede-Strafgesetzbuches ändern,
um ja diesem großen Problem Einhalt,
zu bieten. Das wird begrüßt vom Deutschen Richterbund, der anmerkt,
das Recht sei damals gegen den Rat aller Expertinnen und Experten verschärft worden.
Die vermeintlich gute Tat des Aufklärens habe sich zum Bumerang gewandelt.
Der Der Deutsche Anwaltsverein begrüßt das ebenfalls und wir behandeln das hier
deshalb, weil es natürlich auch große Konsequenzen für diese ursprünglich geplante
Chat-Kontrolle-Ansätze.
Gehabt hätte, wenn die dann demnächst von der AI überwacht werden und vor Gericht
landen, wenn sie sich fröhlich austauschen und ihre Jugend genießen.
Dann möchte ich noch den Fundraiser auf GoFundMe benennen.
Wir werben ja relativ selten, wenn irgendwo Geld gesammelt wird,
aber wir haben ja auch beim Camp Julian Hessenthaler hier gehabt.
Ihr erinnert euch sicherlich alle an unsere Live-Sendung vom Camp.
Wir haben äußerst gutes Feedback für unseren unterhaltsamen,
gewitzten und geschichtsträchtigen Gast bekommen.
Ich hatte mich damals ja auch sehr darüber gefreut, dass viele im Anschluss an die Sendung,
Spenden vorbeigebracht haben oder angebracht haben für Julian Hessenthaler und
da gibt Das ist jetzt eine GoFundMe, den Ibiza-Fundraiser,
für mehr politische Transparenz und ich,
lese jetzt einfach mal den Text.
Der Ibiza-Skandal war leider nicht der erste und letzte Fall versuchter Korruption,
der in Österreich aufgedeckt wurde.
Meistens geschehen solche Vorfälle im Verborgenen, ohne dass die Öffentlichkeit davon erfährt.
Thomas berichtet regelmäßig davon, Julian hat davon berichtet.
Doch wir sind entschlossen, dies zu ändern.
Ursprünglich starteten wir diese Kampagne, um Julian Hessenthaler,
dem Ibiza-Detektiv, aus seiner Insolvenz zu helfen.
Doch es stellte sich heraus, dass er keine Gelder annehmen darf.
Nach intensiven Gesprächen mit seinem Umfeld haben wir einen neuen Plan entwickelt,
um die Bekämpfung von Korruption und die Aufdeckung von Missständen in den Fokus zu rücken.
Unsere Mission ist klar, mit Ihrer Unterstützung können wir Gelder bereitstellen,
um Recherchen durchzuführen und Whistleblower abzusichern, damit sie nicht mit
Existenzängsten kämpfen müssen.
Jeder Beitrag zählt und jeder Euro fließt in die Aufdeckung von Korruption und
die Förderung der Transparenz. Aber das ist noch nicht alles.
Wir rufen nicht nur dazu auf zu spenden, sondern auch dazu, diese Botschaft
weiterzutragen. Tragen Sie diese Kampagne mit Ihren Freunden usw.
Machen Sie mit und werden Sie Teil dieser Bewegung. Gemeinsam können wir die
Korruption aufdecken und bekämpfen und Österreich zu einem besseren Ort für alle machen.
Ich habe, weil das hier noch etwas unkonkret ist, den Julian gefragt,
meinte so, sag mal, ist das legit? Und dann sagt er, ja, ist es.
Die Leute sind legitim und sollen wir gerne darauf hinweisen.
Bei der Gelegenheit möchte ich auch etwas früher als normal,
also wir machen es gleich nochmal in den Terminen, aber an diesem Freitag,
für diejenigen, die vor den Terminen immer einschlafen und dann von unserer
Melodie wieder aufwachen, dieser Freitag, 24.
November, da ist eine Veranstaltung in Berlin mit Julian Hessenthaler und Friederik Obermeier.
Das ist einer von den Obermeiers, die Obermeiers kennst du, die Investigativjournalisten.
Die sind ein paar, aber damit das keiner weiß, schreiben die ihre Nachnamen
unterschiedlich. Die beiden.
Von denen einer, also der wird den Julian Hessenthaler interviewen.
In Berlin, in Betanien.
Und übrigens sind die Obermeyers kein Paar, die haben sich vor einiger Zeit getrennt.
Aber ich finde das einfach super, dass die so mit diesen beiden,
die heißen beide gleich, das ist doch einfach total spannend.
Man sagt automatisch Oberbayer, aber mit A, ne der mit E.
Also ein lustiges Phänomen, die haben ja wirklich, ich würde schätzen in wenigen
Jahren sich zu den wichtigsten, investigativsten oder den einflussreichsten
oder erfolgreichsten Investigativjournalisten Deutschlands gemacht, oder?
Kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber wenn du das sagst, dann nehme ich das mal an.
Ja, also ich bin auf jeden Fall, ich hoffe, dass ich es schaffe,
dort hinzukommen und gleich in den Terminen sagen wir genau,
wo das ist und da erwähne ich dann auch den Link in den Shownotes,
wo man die Tickets kaufen kann, die nicht besonders teuer sind.
Vorher möchten wir aber natürlich noch auf unsere eigenen Events hinweisen,
denn der 730 C3, der wie ihr wisst vom 27.
Bis zum 30.12. in Hamburg stattfindet...
Also ist nicht unser Event.
Deins nicht, ne. Ich bin an der Organisation beteiligt.
Ja okay, gut. Aber es ist kein LMP. Wir versuchen das mal klarzustellen.
Chaos Communication Kongress präsentiert von Logbuch Nespriti.
Genau, es wird von uns präsentiert und es wird von uns approved.
Also der 37c3,
jetzt sind die Vorverkaufstermine bekannt gegeben worden und die offenen Vorverkaufstermine
für Leute, die nicht als Engel schon Voucher haben und ähnliches, sind der 29.
November um 20 Uhr, das ist ein Mittwoch, das ist der Mittwoch in etwas mehr
als, Also ziemlich genau einer Woche.
Und der Mittwoch, der 29. November um 20 Uhr und der Samstag,
der 2. Dezember um 15 Uhr.
Da finden also öffentliche Verkäufe statt, wo man ohne irgendwelche Voucher-Tickets.
Kaufen kann. Was bedeutet das?
Erstens, keine Sorge, auch für diese Voucherphasen sind die Kontingente begrenzt.
Das heißt, es wird zu diesen Terminen auf jeden Fall Tickets geben und das werden
auch viele Tickets sein.
Was ich glaube, wie das passieren wird, ist am Mittwoch, den 29.
November, sind die Tickets in kürzester Zeit weg.
Das wird irgendwie so, da wird dann genau um diese Uhrzeit, 20 Uhr am Mittwoch
wird der Ticket Sale freigeschaltet und dann müsst ihr in der Sekunde neu laden,
dann müsst ihr einen Captcha lösen und dann werdet ihr in der Warteliste sein.
Und es ist relativ wahrscheinlich, dass es euch passiert, dass ihr in dieser Warteschlange...
Zu weit hinten seid und es beim ersten Mal nicht schafft.
Dazu zwei Dinge. Erstens, nicht alle kaufen alles zu Ende und diese Warteschlangenpositionen
expiren ja auch irgendwann, so dass es durchaus sinnvoll ist,
den Browser-Tab auch länger offen zu halten,
bis ihr vielleicht glaubt, dass ihr, wenn ihr vielleicht glaubt,
ihr kämpft nicht dran, dass ihr eben trotzdem drin bleibt.
Zweitens, am Samstag, den 2.
Dezember um 15 Uhr solltet ihr es nochmals versuchen, weil üblicherweise,
wenn der Andrang hoch ist, heißt es ja nicht, dass auch der letzte Verkaufstermin
wirklich komplett überrannt wird. Das war beim Camp ja auch so.
Da gab es auch mehrere Verkaufstermine.
Die ersten Verkaufstermine waren dann alle immer schnell weg.
Und der letzte Verkaufstermin, der war dann anfangs weg, so für eine halbe Stunde.
Und dann plötzlich sind die ganzen alten Wartelisten, Positionen oder reservierten Tickets expired.
Und dann war es auf einmal noch tagelang, dass es da Tickets gab.
So oder so würde ich euch empfehlen, an beiden Terminen teilzunehmen.
Und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ihr enorm gute Chancen habt,
da am Ende auch Tickets zu bekommen.
Man muss sich eben nur ein bisschen Mühe geben. Natürlich würde ich auch damit
rechnen, dass wenige Tage vorher, aufgrund von Erkrankungen.
Schicksalsschlägen, unvorhergesehenen Geburtstagen und so weiter,
verliebt plötzlich nochmal Tickets irgendwo spontan im Umlauf sind und wer sich
da bemüht, den rechne ich nach wie vor relativ hohe Chancen aus.
Standardticket kostet 175 Euro, der durchschnittliche Eintrittspreis müsste eher so bei 180 liegen.
Also wer es sich leisten kann, kann gerne zum Supporterticket greifen.
Man kann auch immer mehr bezahlen, so Supportertickets um 200 Euro.
Und wer den ganzen Kram, also Businessreise vom Arbeitgeber bezahlt bekommt,
Möge dann auch, sagen wir mal, Businesspreise zahlen, ja, also dass diese Veranstaltung
eine viertägige IT-Security- und Gesellschaftskonferenz von,
denke ich mal, doch relativ bedeutsamen Inhalten und Größe so günstig verkauft,
wird, es liegt halt daran, dass es sich an eine Community richtet und wer das
da als Dienstreise sieht,
oder.
Bezahlt,
bekommt, der darf dann auch gerne ehrlich sein. und das Business-Ticket ab 550 kaufen.
Wer jemals bei irgendeiner Security-Konferenz war, weiß, dass das immer noch,
ein äußerst geringer Preis ist für eine solche Veranstaltung.
Natürlich für Leute, die sich der Community zugehörig fühlen und diese Preise
von über 100 Euro nicht in der Lage sind zu bezahlen, gibt es das Friends-Ticket,
dafür müsst ihr euch halt mal direkt beim Organisationsteam melden,
so eure Situation schildern und dann gibt es da auch Möglichkeiten.
Also, für alle was dabei, aber klar, diejenigen, die da sind,
werden sich ein bisschen darum bemühen müssen. So ist das.
Ja es ist teuer geworden solche Veranstaltungen durchzuführen.
Also gerade Veranstaltungsbranche ist wirklich nach Corona durchs Feuer gelaufen.
Erstmal weil sie natürlich überleben mussten, aber danach gab es da ich würde
mal fast sagen tektonische Verschiebungen.
Also viele Leute sind, ich denke generell war das ja in dieser Corona Zeit so,
dass sich viele auch über Sinn und Wert ihrer eigenen Beschäftigung Gedanken
gemacht haben, weil sie einfach mal diesen Break auf einmal hatten,
mal über alles nachzudenken und
viele haben dann nicht mehr in diesem Veranstaltungsbereich gearbeitet,
weil das halt oft auch so ein Bereich ist, der mit sehr schlechter Bezahlung
daher kam, mit sehr viel Stress, sehr viel Zeitdruck etc.
Dementsprechend sind viele abgewandert. Die, die dann geblieben sind,
die wollten sich aber auch richtig bezahlen lassen.
Dadurch, dass dann eben die Nachfrage größer war als das Angebot,
konnten dann diese Preise auch erzielt werden.
Und ja, das drückt sich natürlich dann auch in den Gesamtkosten aus,
wenn man so ein komplettes Konferenzzentrum mietet.
Das ist alles nicht billig.
Insofern ist es immer noch ein Discountpreis, auch wenn ich natürlich sehe,
dass viele dann vielleicht noch irgendwelchen historischen Preisen nachtrauern,
wie dieser Kongress irgendwann mal gekostet hat,
aber ist auch nicht mehr die gleiche Veranstaltung und es gibt auf jeden Fall immer Wege,
Härten ausgleichen zu lassen und da soll man sich dann auch nicht zu schade
sein, diese Wege dann zu beschreiten, wenn es denn wirklich erforderlich ist.
Ja, dann können wir ja mal die anderen Termine verkünden, oder?
Jo.
Okay.
Ich hab das Event gerade schon erwähnt, das ist die Konferenz Organized Crime,
a global business, die findet das ganze Wochenende, also 24, 25 und 26.
November in Berlin-Stadt in Bethanien, im Studio 1 des Kunstquartiers im Mariannenplatz,
2 und wird durchgeführt vom Disruption Network Lab.
Du kennst die Tatjana Bracicelli auch, ne? Die hat das mal wieder kuratiert.
Und genau am Freitag, dem 24. von 17.15 bis 18.45 die Keynote von Friedrich,
Obermeier,
und Julian Hessenthaler zusammen.
Das Ganze kann man sich auch im Stream anschauen, aber man kann auch Tickets
dafür kaufen und so weiter, also Link ist in den Shownotes.
Ich will versuchen, es dort hinzuschaffen. Mal schauen, ob es klappt,
ansonsten bin ich auch zum Stream schauen verdammt.
Dann haben wir den 37C3 ja gerade schon erwähnt.
Und euch die Vorverkaufstermine genannte, dass ihr keine Ausreden mehr habt.
Und der 37. Zei wird diesmal auch einen Azubi-Tag haben.
Es gibt ja beim Kongress immer den Jung-Hacker-Tag.
Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es den dieses Jahr auch?
Ich habe davon noch nichts gelesen.
Nichts davon gehört, aber der ist doch Tradition, oder?
Vielleicht gab es da jetzt ein Upgrade, jetzt muss man schon Azubi sein,
demnächst gibt es aber auch noch einen Seniorentag.
Mhh.
Ich bin mal, also ich, joa, also mal gucken. Also auf jeden Fall gibt es einen Azubi-Tag, ja.
Und der Azubi-Tag zeichnet,
sich dadurch aus, also richtet sich an Auszubildende oder deren Ausbilderinnen.
Der ist am 29.12., also der 27.
Ist der Tag 1, der 28. Tag 2 Der 29.
Ist der Tag 3 und es handelt sich dabei um einen Freitag, der 29. Dezember.
Und da gibt es vergünstigte Tagestickets für die Zielgruppe.
Das ist, wenn wir hingehen und sagen, ich bin Auszubildende,
kriegst du vergünstigtes Tagesticket. gibt es ein Intro zum CCC und dem Chaos und weitere Dinge.
Den Link auch hier in den Shownotes finde ich auch mal wieder schön,
dass wir uns in diese Richtung wenden.
Wenn ihr an dem Tag teilnehmen möchtet oder Fragen habt, schreibt uns gerne eine Mail an 37c3-azubi.
Und anders als es die E-Mail-Adresse nahelegt, geht es hier nicht darum,
dass ihr einen Ausbildungsplatz bekommt,
sondern schon einen habt. In der E-Mail könnt ihr benennen, wie viele Auszubildende,
aus welchen Ausbildungsberufen möchten teilnehmen, Name des Ausbildungsbetriebs
oder der Ausbildungsstätte, kleine Nachweis- bzw.
Bescheinigung, Berufsstelle, Berufsschule oder sonst was.
Und dann gibt es also ein Ticket, das an dem einen Tag gültig ist.
Ja in dem Zusammenhang der Blogpost greift das auch nochmal auf,
das kann man ja auch gleich nochmal betonen so, wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt,
ja ich bin zwar Azubi aber was hab ich mit Computer Security zu tun und überhaupt
mein Computer benutze ich für Word.
Das ist schon eine Weile her, dass der Chaos Communication Kongress eine Veranstaltung
ist, die ausschließlich von Computernerds in irgendeiner Form gutiert werden
kann, sondern das ist einfach mittlerweile ein breiteres,
kulturelles Gesamtprogramm und Gesamtgeschehen und es gibt viele Vorträge,
die sich mit Sachen beschäftigen, die jetzt vielleicht erstmal auf den ersten
Blick überhaupt nichts mit Computern zu tun haben.
Natürlich die ganzen politischen Datenschutz-Überwachungsthemen etc.,
aber wir haben auch immer schon so Kunst, Kultur und ähnlichen Themen,
geschichtliche Einblicke und einfach unkonventionelle Blicke vielleicht einfach
auf die Welt als solche an sich und da lohnt es sich eigentlich immer mal.
Und selbst wenn euch die Vorträge nicht ansprechen, ist es immer wieder auch
interessant, einfach auch mitzunehmen.
Das hast du jetzt gesagt. Ne, äh, was...
Also was ich immer wieder sehe ist, dass wenn Leute auf den Kongress kommen
und uns überrascht sind von der Dynamik mit der Leute in ihren Projekten Engagement zeigen.
Und auszubilden heißt ja eigentlich auch, dass man sich in gewisser Hinsicht
auch noch in so einen Schutzraum bewegen sollte,
wo man sich spielerisch vielleicht auch ein bisschen an seinen Beruf heranpirscht,
weil man eben noch nicht komplett eingebunden ist, weil man noch nicht so komplett ist.
Und das sollte dann deutlich über Kaffeekochen für die anderen hinausgehen und
ich glaube, man kann da eine ganze Menge mitnehmen aus der Community, in ihrem Ansatz,
wie Lösungen gefunden werden, unkonventionelle Lösungen gefunden werden für
teilweise auch unkonventionelle Probleme und das ist ja nun mal genau das,
mit dem man sich irgendwie auch in einem Unternehmen gut behaupten kann,
wenn man da reinkommt und frische Ansätze zeigt.
Und das kann man, glaube ich, auch im Kongress ganz gut lernen.
Ja, soviel dazu.
Ungefähr 25 Euro pro Person kostet das. Und man kann das auch als Fortbildungstag anbieten.
Ich weiß nur nicht, was das bedeutet. Das ist ja auch nicht weiter beschrieben, aber geht.
Naja das bedeutet wahrscheinlich, dass man das in irgendeiner Form auch angeben
kann offiziell, dass das sozusagen von Firmen und Berufsverbände oder sowas
anerkannt wird, weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Man bekommt am Ende ein Zertifikat.
Na bitte, das ist doch schon mal was.
Das ist was eigenes.
Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Und zum Abschluss, weißt du, haben wir eigentlich in unserer Auseinandersetzung
im Magnetschwebeband schon darüber gesprochen, dass München das auch mal vorhatte?
Nee, haben wir noch nicht angesprochen.
Dann lass mal das jetzt zum Abschluss noch mal kurz erörtern, oder?
Mit dem Magnetschwebeband in München? Ja, kann man machen.
Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn wir einen Bonustrack einspielen,
kommt der dann vor oder nach dem Outro? Hast du dich überhaupt schon zu dem Outro geäußert?
Nee, du hast es ja einfach gemacht. Das war die Folge, wo du auch einfach ein
anderes Intro gemacht hast, also völlig daneben einfach.
Disruption.
Nach zwölf Jahren irgendwie kommst du hier rein.
Disruption, ja ich bin noch in der Lage zu überraschen, das ist die eigentliche Botschaft dabei.
Ja ich wusste nicht, dass du da so einen Druck hattest, das nochmal zu zeigen.
Naja, manchmal. Das Outro versuche ich schon längere Zeit zu finalisieren und
hab mich jetzt einfach mal für eine Variante entschlossen.
Ich hatte da verschiedene im Angebot und ich glaube die passt ganz gut.
Ich frage mich jetzt nur, wenn wir einen Bonustrack spielen,
spielen wir erst das Outro und dann den Bonustrack oder spielen wir erst den
Bonustrack und dann das Outro?
Was ist denn, was ist denn üblich?
Was ist schon üblich? Also bei der Freakshow spiele ich erst das Outro und dann den Bonus-Trick.
Weil das Outro ja auch, sagen wir mal, dafür gedacht ist, Outro zu sein,
um mit unserer Verabschiedung zusammen zu gehen.
Mir fehlt leider noch akustisch jetzt ein bisschen so der Schweller,
auf den wir drauf sprechen können. Das wird gerade noch gefixt.
Und deswegen hab ich das jetzt auch erstmal andersrum gemacht.
Aber ich denke so ist es eigentlich richtig.
Und der Bonustrack, der kommt dann einfach hinterher.
Meinst du?
Ja. Oder meinst du es ist halt, weil wir es selber so gemacht haben?
Dann muss man das Outro hören und weiß gar nicht, ob noch ein Bonustrack kommt.
Ja, das ist auch ein guter Grund das zu Ende zu hören, ne?
Dafür ist es ein bisschen lang vielleicht.
Weißt du wie man das auf Youtube macht?
Like, subscribe, Glocke und dann kommentieren.
Schreibt's mir in die Kommentare.
Schreibt's mir in die Kommentare, like, subscribe, Glocke, Kommentare.
Dann wird der Algorithmus gefilmt, richtig schön.
Aber sowas haben wir ja hier nicht, solche Incentives. Wir können einfach,
wenn wir nach Kommentaren fragen, dann fragen wir, weil wir eure Kommentare auch haben wollen.
Nicht, weil die Kommentare den Algorithmus bruschen.
Sonst würden wir ja einfach keine Inhalte für eine Sendung haben.
Kauft euch unsere Klamotten, werdet Werbeträger für uns und empfehlt uns zu
euren Freunden und kommentiert und macht Notifications an auf eurem Podcatcher.
Nur für uns, sonst nervt das.
Und richtet einen Dauerauftrag ein.
Ja, hat der noch gar nicht? Dann dürfte er das hier gar nicht hören.
Das ist ein Schwarzhörer.
Dauerauftrag ist Liebe.
Wir schicken demnächst die MEZ, die Meta-Ebene-Einzugszentrale.
Die,
gucken, ob ihr neuartige Empfangsgeräte,
habt.
Und dann geht's rund.
Da haben sie doch sicherlich IP.
Ja, da haben sie eine IP-Adresse.
Die haben wir aber bei uns in den Logs gesehen.
Und wie schwarz gehört.
So geht's ja nicht. Heute mache ich mal Outro erst und dann den Bonus-Track,
und dann können wir ja sehen, was besser ankommt. Aber zwei Bonus-Tracks. Zwei?
Klar.
Wie zwei?
Wir können nicht über...
Achso, jetzt weiß ich was du meinst.
Also wir lassen uns das erstmal nochmal mit dem Transrapid erklären,
dann lassen wir uns das nochmal erklären, wie das in Amerika war.
Dann ist endlich Ruhe im Karton.
Und dann kommt ein Outro. Also geht noch ein bisschen weiter die Sendung.
Wir denken es wäre vorbei, aber kommt noch was.
Okay, dann sagen wir erstmal Tschüss oder? Ja. Alles klar.
Ciao ciao.